Exzellent! So Leute, mal ein bisschen was anderes heute. Mal ein bisschen das Spiel
meiner Jugend spielen. Hoffnung es funktioniert. Bin ich ja echt gespannt, ob alles tut. Mal
gucken, wie das ausschaut. Wie ist das denn qualitativ? Qualitativ scheint das ganz okay
zu sein. Ja, sieht ziemlich gut aus. Alles schön geblurrt im Chat. Exzellent, so muss
das sein. So, wunderbar. Ich muss noch ein bisschen heller machen sehe ich gerade. Bisschen
dunkel. Gamma rauf. Oh, jetzt sehe ich ein bisschen mehr. Ihr solltet auch ein bisschen
mehr sehen. Wobei, wird das heller, wenn ich hier umschalte? Wird das heller? Nee, oder?
Für euch macht es keine Auswirkungen, ob ich Gamma hoch mache oder nicht. Ich muss euch
auf jeden Fall, ich muss euch auf jeden Fall das Game ein bisschen heller machen, weil
sonst seht ihr gar nichts. Und dann erzähle ich was zu, weil heute Morgen ging es ja darum,
was ich den ganzen Tag hier Kreiselgrinde online MMO technisch spiele. Ich zeige euch
das einfach mal. Wie mache ich denn jetzt OBS heller? Wie mache ich OBS heller? Zeigt
mal hier, Display Capture, Filter. Hat der mal einen Plan wie man OBS heller macht? Brightness,
ah, hier Gamma. Nice. Ich muss nur mal nebenbei gucken, dass ich nicht verrecke. Ich muss
mal kurz eine Runde sticken, dann sage ich auch was zum Game. Und Filters, Gamma haben
wir jetzt auf, keine Ahnung, Gamma auf 25, 20, 25. Dann machen wir hier den Filter auch
auf Color Correction. Dankeschön für den Sub. Color Correction, Gamma auf 25. Jetzt
müsste es eigentlich passen, jetzt ist es eigentlich hell genug. So, uralt Oldschool
Games Leute, das ist das Spiel meiner Kindheit. Oder was heißt meine Kindheit, meine Jugend.
Gehen eigentlich meine Emotes? Ja, Emotes gehen sehr schön. Hab mir gedacht ich zeige
euch das ein bisschen. So, also Leute, es mag jetzt erstmal ein bisschen chaotisch für
alle sein, ihr habt keine Ahnung was ihr hier seht, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, das
ist für alle Leute, die Dark zum ersten Mal sehen. Wir sind hier auch mitten in PvP Action,
ich habe keine Buffs. Need all Buffs, please. Ohne Buffs kriege ich nichts gebacken, ich
stelle mich mal neben mein Clary, dass ich mich buffen kann. Ja, also was seht ihr hier,
ihr seht das Spiel meiner Jugend, ich glaube es gibt kein Spiel wo ich mehr Zeit drin verbracht
habe als in Dark Hatch of Camelot. Ich habe da drinnen bestimmt, keine Ahnung, zwei Real
Life Jahre an Zeit reingesteckt oder so, richtig heftig. Ich habe sogar, ihr werdet es nicht
glauben, ich habe sogar meine erste Freundin über Dark kennengelernt. Es ist natürlich
gerade Nacht, das ist dumm, man sieht nichts. Ich versuche euch mal so ein bisschen zu erklären
was ihr hier gerade seht. Also wir sind hier im Grenzgebiet und Dark Hatch of Camelot hat
drei Fraktionen. So ein bisschen mal, weiß nicht wer von euch Elder Scrolls gespielt
hat, das ist quasi Oldschool Tinder sozusagen. Ich weiß nicht wer von euch mal Elder Scrolls
online gespielt hat, da gibt es ja auch drei Fraktionen und es wurde von Leuten mitentwickelt
die damals auch an Dark Hatch of Camelot mit gebastelt haben. Es gibt drei Reiche die sich
quasi um, ich zeige euch mal die Karte vom Grenzgebiet, die sich quasi um dieses Grenzgebiet
hier kloppen. Es gibt Albion, da sind wir gerade hier, das ist so mittelalterliches,
angehauchtes, König Arthus ist tot, bla bla bla, keine Ahnung, Story fragt mich nicht
zur Story von diesem Game. Dann gibt es Midgard, das ist für die ganzen Nordmänner unter uns
und dann gibt es Hibernia, das ist so für, wie wir früher gesagt haben, das darf ich
jetzt nicht sagen, Naturliebhaber, drücken wir es mal so aus. So und jedes dieser drei
Reiche, es gibt noch eine gemeinsame Insel, jedes dieser drei Reiche hat ein Grenzgebiet,
Baumschmuser, ne ne das war schon noch ein bisschen heftiger. Jedes dieser drei Reiche
hat ein Grenzgebiet, ich stehe jetzt einfach nur sinnlos rum, hier oben rennen übrigens
gerade die Gegner rum. By the way, alles was ihr hier seht, sind echte Spieler, ne. Also
jeder dieser Chars, die hier rumrennen, sind echte Spieler. Also nix Bots, hier ist nix,
hier ist nix mit Bots. Es sind gerade, ich zeige euch das mal, es sind gerade 2000 Leute
an. Da haben gerade alle den Stream geguckt, lull. Lenkt mich nicht ab Leute. Was wollte
ich gerade sagen? Genau, also jedes reicherten Grenzgebiet mit insgesamt, ich glaube wieviel
sind es dann? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Festungen und Türme, die man erobern kann. Das ist Super
Mario, das ist Mario Kart Musik, ja. So, und aktuell, normalerweise, wie ihr es hier seht,
HIP ist grün, Midgar ist blau und Albion ist eigentlich rot. Das Problem ist, was ihr
hier gerade seht, von Albion ist fast nix rot. Albion ist quasi zu 90% grün und blau. Was
halt dafür spricht, dass wir gerade gangbanked werden von allen Seiten. So, und was wir hier
gerade machen ist, ich bin in einer BG, da sind insgesamt gerade, ich kann es euch zeigen,
achso ich bin gar nicht in der BG gejoined, sollte ich vielleicht mal machen. BG, Count,
wir haben Hund, Alter, guckt euch das mal an, wir haben 190 Leute, 190 Leute in der BG,
Alter, geht's ab. Ja, so und jetzt spiele ich einfach mal ein bisschen Laber dabei. Ich
weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Also, um eine Festung zu erobern, wie ihr das wahrscheinlich
gerade alle da schon seht, hier guck mal, drei Rammen dran ans Tor und dann wird das
Tor aufgerammt. Eigentlich, eigentlich müsste ich mich jetzt auch in diese Ramme hier reinsetzen
und mitrammen, weil, wenn ich nicht mitramme, dann wird mich gleich unser Ober-BG-Leader,
BG ist Battle Group, dann wird mich gleich unser Ober-BG-Leader, das ist der hier, der
mit der Mütze auf hier, da muss man immer aufpassen, was man macht, wenn man da das
falsche macht, ist man direkt der BG-Band schon raus. Wenn man sich da nicht in die
Ramme setzt, wenn der sagt, man soll sich in die Ramme setzen, dann flippt er voll aus.
Der ist Grieche und seitdem ich da täglich im Discord, ah jetzt übrigens das Tor gerade
aufgegangen, seitdem ich da täglich im Discord bin und zuhöre, habe ich erstmal gelernt,
wie viele Schimpfwörter es auf Griechisch alles gibt und zu wie vielen unterschiedlichen
Gelegenheiten man mal Lacka verwenden kann. Ja, so, und wenn man eine Festung erobern
will, muss man das Tor aufmachen, reingehen und den Lord killen. Der Lord ist hier oben,
das Problem ist, dass die Gegner hier im Raum sitzen und, nö, keine Gegner mehr da.
Und ich hoffe jetzt wird es gleich ein bisschen ruhiger, weil ich habe mitten im Keep halt
umgelockt, weil es keine so schlaue Idee gewesen ist, damit ich den Streamer machen kann und
den Zerg nicht verliere. Richtig oldschool. Ich weiß, dass es nicht für jeden was ist.
Normalerweise, wenn ich was spiele, dann ist es eher Battlefield oder Call of Duty oder
sowas. In letzter Zeit machen wir hauptsächlich irgendwelche Technik-Streams, aber ich habe
mir gedacht, ich streue jetzt einfach mal eine Runde das Game, wo ich glaube ich mit
Abstand die meiste Zeit meines Lebens drin verbracht habe und was ich gerade jeden Tag
immer noch spiele. Übrigens, alles echte Spieler und ich hoffe wir kriegen heute richtig
geile Action mit 100 vs. 100 vs. 100. Ja, und wenn ihr was wissen wollt zum Spiel,
könnt ihr mich einfach fragen. Ich habe ja genug Zeit und genug Blick hier nebenbei
auf den Chat. Das da oben sind meine Spells. Also man sieht das Spiel ist relativ komplex,
weil man einsteigen will. Was ist denn hier im Chat schon wieder los? Wir haben das Keep
nicht gekriegt. Man kann mit einer Gilde das Keep claimen und dann gehört einem das Keep
und kann das aufleveln und das Keep ist ja nicht die Festung. Kann das aufleveln und
dann kriegt es da neue Türme und stärkere Wachen und sowas, aber wir haben es nicht
bekommen. Übrigens gerade Nacht. Dark ist Nacht, immer ziemlich dunkel. Ich hoffe ich
habe das mit der Gammakorrektur so hinbekommen, dass man alles erkennt. Gibt es ein Scoreboard?
Ja, es gibt ein Scoreboard. Oh, ich hab den an. Wo sind sie denn hin? Ach da, gut. Ja,
es gibt ein Scoreboard. Scoreboard ist slash stats. Aber ich habe gerade eben erst eingeloggt.
Es gibt kein Voip. Nein, es gibt kein Voip. Aber man kann in diesem Scoreboard, kann
man halt gucken, was weiß ich, wer die meisten Kills hat, wer die meisten APs gemacht hat
und sonst was. Da sind wir eigentlich immer relativ weit oben. Wir spielen immer mit den
gleichen Leuten mehr oder weniger, mehr oder weniger in der Gruppe. Ja und zu der Frage,
ob das die offiziellen Server sind? Nein, das sind nicht die offiziellen Server. Das
ist ein FreeShot. Das ist ein FreeShot und zwar Celestius. Wie soll man das ausspricht?
Celestius? Celestias? Keine Ahnung, ich hab immer... Celestius RVR. Kann man kostenlos
drauf spielen. Es ist auch auf... Ich lasse jetzt mal die Lampe an. Normalerweise gilt
das in diesem Spiel als übelst, übelst nubig, wenn man die Lampe anmacht nachts. Aber ich
lasse mal die Lampe an, damit ihr ein bisschen besser was seht. So, ich mache jetzt mal
Ram-Action, sonst kriege ich Anschluss vom BG-Leader. Ne, Ramme ist voll. Gut, dann mache
ich nix. Ja. Da hat man dran gewöhnt, was jetzt zu spielen und dabei zu streamen, so
und da bin ich gar nicht gewöhnt. So. Tja. Es gibt es dann am Anfang noch zu sagen, also
gestern gab es die mit Abstand krassesten Fights aller Zeiten. Das war... Sowas habe
ich noch nie gesehen. 45 Minuten Keep-Defense mit Türmen und Festung und alles. Danach
in einem alten verlassenen Dorf im Midgard nochmal 100 vs. 100 vs. 100 geht richtig
ab. Ja. Es braucht natürlich kein Abo, es braucht kein Abo, weil es ist ein Free-Sharten,
das ist kostenlos. Könnt ihr spielen und das PvE ist hier auch relativ reduziert. Also
ihr seid ziemlich schnell Level 50. Ich bin auch 50. Ihr seid relativ schnell Level 50
und seid auch relativ schnell equipped. Ich hoffe, dass der Spielsound ist von der Lautstärke
her okay. Ich habe den Spielsound relativ leise. Müssen wir mal sagen, ob das okay
ist, ob man noch ein bisschen was hört. Man muss sagen, Dark ist etwas in die Jahre gekommen,
was den Sound angeht. Also die Sounds waren noch nie sonderlich gut. Dark Sounds sind
eher ein bisschen nervig auf Dauer. Übrigens wisst ihr, was man machen muss, um seine Heiler
richtig abzufucken? Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal. Wenn ihr eure Heiler ärgern wollt, nachdem
ihr in den Turm eingenommen habt, geht ihr oben auf den Turm, nehmt Anlauf und springt
vom Turm runter. Da denken die nämlich immer, man kriegt richtig fett Damage von den Gegnern
rein und wassten ihre Instant Heals auf dich. Jetzt mögen die nicht. Ich weiß das, weil
ich spiele selber in der Regel Support. Also ihr seht, alles Spieler hier. Alles komplett
Spieler und keiner außer Lancelotti hat die Lampe an. Nur Noobs haben die Lampe an und
ich. Ansonsten, ich glaube, wir gehen jetzt aufs Boot. Gehen wir aufs Boot? Nein, wir
gehen nicht aufs Boot. Wir rennen irgendwo anders hin. Nee, keine Ahnung, was wir vorhaben.
Ich bin jetzt aber nicht im Discord. Normalerweise bin ich im Discord und hör zu, was wir machen.
Bin ich jetzt? Ja. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was wir machen. Ich hoffe einfach unser Vorläufer
macht das ordentlich. Gab es nicht noch ein weiteres Camelot-Game? Doch, es gab Camelot
unchained, das wird aber nie fertig. Das wurde gekickstarted, crowd founded und die Typen
hatten irgendwie keinen Bock mehr. Ich weiß nicht, was die treiben. Übrigens, ich wundere,
wenn das ein bisschen laggy ist. Ist das eigentlich okay von der Bildqualität her? Ich hab's mir
gerade mal angeguckt auf dem zweiten Bildschirm und ich muss sagen, dafür, dass es Nacht ist,
sieht es eigentlich verhältnismäßig crisp aus. Dauoc ist bekannt dafür, dass es nachts
sackdunkel ist, deswegen hab ich auch schon ein bisschen heller gemacht. Ja, sieht eigentlich
ganz okay aus, ich guck's mir grad an. Jo, also um auf die Sache einzugehen, die eben
einer im Chat gefragt hat, also sind das hier oben meine Spells und was spiel ich für eine
Klasse? Ich stell mich mal ein bisschen nebenhin und erzähl mal was. Ich kann hier eh nicht
viel machen, wenn wir diesen Turm hier einnehmen. Guck, dieser Turm gehört nicht uns, sieht
man an der Fahne oder man kann alternativ auch hier auf der Map gucken, ob uns dieser
Turm gehört, aber dieser Turm gehört uns nicht. Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal zu, wie
wir den Turm einnehmen und ich erzähl mal was zu dem, was eben im Chat gefragt wird.
Also ja, das hier oben sind meine Spells und was ich für eine Klasse spiele ist, oh wie
heißt denn das auf Deutsch? Hexe heißt das glaube ich, Sorcerer auf Englisch. Um euch
das zu erklären, müsste ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen, was es in DAOG für Klassen gibt,
aber ich mein wir haben ja Zeit. Also DAOG ist oldschool was Klassen angeht, also oldschooliger
kannst du kaum werden, was MMOs angeht. Du hast reine Support Klassen, du hast reine
Damage Klassen, du hast reine Range Klassen, du hast reine Nahkampf Klassen, du hast nicht
das was du aus modernen MMOs kennst, wo man auch als Support easy solo leveln kann und
sowas, das gibt es hier nicht. Also wenn du hier sagen wir mal, wenn du Clary spielst
hier so wie der Tarmac zum Beispiel, dann kannst du zwar eine Damage Skillung machen,
die ist tatsächlich auch gar nicht so schlecht, aber dann will dich niemand in der Gruppe
haben. Also wenn du Support spielst, muss dir das auch wirklich Spaß machen Support
zu spielen und dementsprechend hast du in DAOG auch eine riesen Klassenauswahl von Nahkampfhybrid
bis Nahkampf Fulltank, bis Damage Caster, bis Support Caster, das ist alles dabei. So
und eine Mechanik die DAOG so ein bisschen abgrenzt von jedem anderen Spiel und von
jedem anderen MMO was ich kenne ist das CC. Man kennt ja CC vielleicht, also Crowd Control,
man kennt das vielleicht aus World of Warcraft oder aus, ich glaube bei Halo Scrolls online
gibt es auch sowas. Da kann man Gegner kurz betäuben oder sowas, das geht hier in DAOG
auch, aber hier ist es viel krasser. Wenn du hier nicht aufpasst und dich einer richtig
CCsst, du stehst zwei Minuten rum. Du kannst Gegner betäuben, du kannst Gegner routen,
du kannst, also wenn du hier nicht aufpasst, stehst du zwei Minuten rum und kannst sich
am Fight teilnehmen. So und was ich hier spiele ist quasi die Haupt-CC-Klasse von Albion.
Das heißt ich bin eigentlich dafür da, dass die Gegner nichts machen können, wenn wir
auf Gegner treffen. Aktuell zergen wir einfach nur sinnlos durch die Gegend. Mit 180 Spielern,
das ist mega krasser Zerke gerade am Start. Guck mal, seht ihr wie das ruckelt? Ich meine
ich habe keinen schlechten Rechner, aber DAOG bringt noch den Rechner zum ruckeln. Noch
einen kurzen Bom-Bom mir reinhauen. Es ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, dass ich
schon relativ früh, Herzog zu Keller, Dankeschön für den Sub. Gar nicht so schlecht, dass ich
früh angehabt zu streamen, da ist nämlich die Action noch nicht so krass. Und wir machen
hauptsächlich ein bisschen Keep-Rates und machen Albion wieder rot und da kann ich euch
wenigstens ein bisschen das Game erklären bevor es gleich 100 vs. 100 vs. 100 geht.
Ich hoffe es gibt heute richtig Action, gestern war wie gesagt richtig krass. Wie muss das
damals gewesen sein, lief das überhaupt zu Release? Naja zu Release gab es keine 100
vs. 100 vs. 100 Kämpfe oder heute ist es ja 180 vs. 180 vs. 180 oder sowas. Gab es nicht,
es gab damals vielleicht 40 vs. 40 vs. 40 und es hat geruckelt as fuck. 3 FPS und die
Leute haben damals gesagt, ja früher sah es schlechter aus, aber nicht wirklich viel,
die Leute haben damals gesagt man soll den Umhang ausziehen, dass man weniger Animationen
erzeugt. Cloak off, Cloak off, leck Cloak off. Du konntest damals im Prinzip, wisst
ihr wie man früher Dark gespielt hat im Zerg mit einem alten Rechner 2005? So, so hat man
Dark FVR gespielt früher, dass es nicht ruckelt. Man ist einfach gerade ausgelaufen, hat auf
den Boden gekrackt. Ohne Scheiß, es war wirklich so. Du bist nur so gelaufen, weil sonst du
sein Geleckt hat. Ja das waren aber noch andere Zeiten, ich meine das Game kam wann raus 2002
oder 2001 oder so, das ist uralt. Es hatte letztens 20 jähriges Jubiläum. Ich hoffe
die Musik ist nicht zu laut. Ich habe mir gedacht ich mache ein bisschen Musik im Hintergrund
an, weil ganz ehrlich die Musik ist ein ticken zu laut. Ganz ehrlich die Dark Sounds sind
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig geil. Dafak warum sind da so viele Spieler? Weil wir BG FVR
spielen. Alter wie es ruckelt, wie es ruckelt. Es sind übrigens mehr Spieler als auf dem
Live Server. Was zensiert den Chat? Ich will nicht, dass die Ansagen irgendwie geleakt
werden, die unser großer BG Anführer hier macht. Außerdem will ich nicht, dass die
Leute die Guilden Chat leaken oder sowas. Die sollen ja schon im Private schreiben können
und das die ganze Welt sieht. So sieht es aus. Um auch mal was zu meinen Spells zu sagen.
Achja ich muss vorher noch was anderes sagen. In Dark ist das folgendermaßen. Für alle
die vielleicht Bock haben sich das anzugucken. In Dark ist das so. Man levelt von 1-50. Gibt
es Arena PVP? Das ist nicht direkt was du dir darunter vorstellst, aber es gibt etwas
ähnliches. Also Instanzen gibt es gar nicht. Das ist alles eine einheitliche Welt und nicht
sogar relativ groß. Was es gibt? Es gibt im PVP Gebiet eine Insel und auf dieser Insel
kommt öfters mal vor, dass Gruppen versus Gruppen kämpfen. Wobei das nicht nur auf
der Insel vorkommt, sondern eigentlich random überall. Und die Gruppen sind ja auch größer
als in anderen MMOs. Man hat nämlich 8 Leute. Der Ingame Chat macht sich gerade drüber
lustig dass ich die Lampe an habe. Weil ich habe euch ja gesagt nur Loops haben die Lampe
an. Was zur Gruppe? Das Spiel ist mega komplex für Leute die anfangen. Einsteigerfreundlich
kann man nicht sagen, aber man kommt gut rein. Dadurch dass hier gerade auf dem Server nicht
so ultra krasses Elite PVP abgeht, sondern man einfach in der BG joinen kann und bisschen
sinnlos rumzerren. Ja Spells erkläre ich gleich, aber vorher muss ich noch was anderes sagen
und zwar Endour Clevel mal von 1-50. Ob ich Delay habe? Ich habe kein Delay ich habe
nur zensiert. Also ja jetzt aber zum eigentlichen was ich sagen wollte.
Also mein Level von 1-50 erstmal. Meistens PvE, also gegen Monster, aber in Gruppe in
achter Gruppe in der Regel. Und eins was ich den Entwicklern von Dark bis heute wirklich
hoch anrechne ist, man hat nie Level Cap erhöht.
Man hat nie das Level Cap erhöht, also das Spiel kam raus, es war Level 50, Max Level
und selbst mit dem letzten Addon war es immer noch 50. Aber in Dark ist das auch ein bisschen
anders. Man levelt von 1-50 und dann ist es eigentlich gut, dann hat man alle Spells und
sowas, die es gibt. Aber was man danach macht ist, man sammelt Reichspunkte und levelt damit
seinen Realm-Rank. RR sagt jeder, RR. Tamek sagt er hat keinen Helm auf meinem Stream,
stimmt? Er hat keinen Helm, das ist richtig. Guck mal hier, er hat keinen Helm. No Helmet,
no Helmet. Ich habe übrigens auch die alten Models. Das Spiel hat neue Models, da sehen
die Charaktere ein bisschen besser aus. Genau und wenn man Level 50 erreicht hat, fängt
man halt an RR zu sammeln. Ich bin in 6L8, es geht bis 14, also da hat man ein bisschen
was zu tun. Und von diesen Punkten, die man hier macht im PvP, kann man sich dann zusätzliche
Fähigkeiten kaufen. Und die sind halt richtig OP, wenn man davon viele hat. Also es lohnt
sich auch PvP zu machen. Man kann sich davon beispielsweise immer kaufen, dass seine Zauber
höheres Level haben, dass man mehr kritische Treffer macht, dass man sich von jeglichem
CC befreien kann, dass man Gegner routen kann, dass man nicht mehr unterbrochen werden kann
beim Zaubern, dass man mehr Geschicklichkeit hat, schneller Zaubern. Also die Fähigkeiten,
die man sich kaufen kann von den Reichspunkten sind eigentlich das, was Dark im Prinzip ausmacht,
PvP technisch. Also es ist ein mega Unterschied, ob du RR1 versus RR8 oder so spielst, du kriegst
einfach auf den Sack. Ja RR14 wirst du hier auch nicht erreichen. Bis RR10 geht es halbwegs
schnell. Danach kannst du es vergessen. So, und jetzt war es zu den Spells. Da ist auch
welche gefragt, da muss ich mal kurz einen Drang reinhauen. Das mache ich, das sage
ich gleich, wenn man den, übrigens ihr erkennt hier gerade nichts, das ist normal. Wir versuchen
den Boss des Keeps zu killen, der Boss ist da, guck mal, guck mal, hier, hier, da, man
sieht ihn, da, hier, da ist er, jetzt aber tot. Man hat kaum was gesehen, so viele Spieler
sind da gerade dran. Nice, das rumgezerge. Ja, ich sticke jetzt mal, das macht man übrigens,
das machen normalerweise auch nur die Noobs, habe ich mich früher lustig darüber gemacht,
wenn die Leute quasi hier im Stick durchs Grenzgebiet gerannt sind. Normalerweise, wenn
man cool sein will, die stickt man und läuft unstickt. Genau, während wir hier den Turm
aufmachen, was zu den Spells. Also, Daug ist nicht das einsteigerfreundlichste Game und
das liegt mit daran, dass es Klassen gibt, die unglaublich viele Abilities und Zauber
haben. Ich habe zum Beispiel hier insgesamt drei Leisten, alles mit Zaubern und Abilities
voll, plus noch eine zweite Leiste und über die anderen Leisten auch noch ein bisschen
Zeug verteilt, was ich mir auf Makros gebunden habe. Wir haben null Enemys, ja, das sagt,
ich wollte euch eigentlich ein paar PvP Kämpfe gegen echte Gegner zeigen, weil so Keeps einnehmen
ist langweilig. Aber was willst du machen, also ich gucke mir das jetzt mal eine Stunde
an oder eineinhalb Stunden und wenn keine Gegner auftauchen, dann habe ich auch keinen
Bock, weil das ist echt langweilig sonst. Genau, also es gibt viele Klassen, die unglaublich
viele Abilities und Spells haben. Ich habe allein schon hier drei Leisten voll und noch
zusätzliche Spells, die ich auf Keybindings gebunden habe. Alter, 180 Alps wälzen sich
durchs Grenzgebiet. Guckt euch das mal an, guckt euch das mal an. Ich kann es nur noch
mal hervorheben, alles echte Spieler auf einem Free-Shot, der von Fans betrieben wird.
Was ist das für ein Game, das ist Dark Edge of Camelot, das beste PvP Spiel, was es hier
gegeben hat und das Spiel, wo ich mit Abstand die meiste Zeit in meinem Leben drin verbracht
habe. Ich habe bestimmt zwei, zwei, wenn nicht sogar mehr Real Life Jahre insgesamt in dieses
Spiel gesteckt. Richtig heftig. Hier guckt mal, unser großer Anführer, da ist er. Malaka
Ink. Kops ist der beste Wizard auf dem Server. Ja, er ist immer Top-Score-Bot. Er muss der
beste Wizard sein. Und all my Group-Mates are best in class. Bisschen Schleim. Ja, leider,
gerade nicht so viel Spannung, weil sinnloses Keep gerade. Aber was willst du machen? Übrigens,
wenn ihr was wissen wollt, schreibt in Wubblos davor im Chat, dass ich es auch sehe. So, wir
haben übrigens, genau, jetzt weiß ich, was ich sagen wollte. Bevor ich mal ein bisschen
was zu den einzelnen Spells erkläre, was ich sagen wollte. Dark ist noch Oldschool-MMO
in der Form, dass du acht, während die den Tower raiden, sage ich was zu. Aber ich muss
mal kurz die Wachen CCen. Achtung, Wachen CC, easy win. Das ist immer geil, du CCs die
Wachen, die werden instant rausgekloppt. Welchen hat denn der jetzt gestunt, den da? Oh ne,
lass mich in Ruhe Wache. Mach die Wache platt. Ja, Dark ist in dem Fall noch Oldschool, dass
du acht Leute in der Gruppe hast und ich will mal gerade ein bisschen was zu unserem, was
da gerade passiert. Ja, es ist schwierig zu erklären, wenn man das Spiel noch nie gespielt
hat. Wir spielen PvP und raiden ein paar Festungen, weil die Gegner sich gedacht haben, unser
komplettes Grenzgebiet zu erobern heute Vormittag. Nur leider sind keine Gegner mehr da, die
haben sich alle verpisst und die Festungen sind jetzt leer, nur noch ein paar Wachen
am Start. Das heißt wir können jetzt im Prinzip einfach das Tor auframmen und Gachibas ans
Tor das Tor auframmen und den Lord killen und fertig. Ich hoffe es gibt nachher noch
ein bisschen Action. Wie gesagt, gestern war mega krass. Band XL, danke für den Sub.
Genau, also ich wollte noch was zum Kumpelsetup sagen. Hast du mal LoL gespielt? Ne, ich mag
keine MOBAs. MOBAs ist nix für mich. Ich müsste mir übrigens mal ein paar Buffs holen, ich
hab nur die billigen, die billigen Clary Buffs. Sag mal, das stimmt doch mit meiner Leiste
hier nicht, oder? Meine Leiste kaputt. Ich hasse das, wenn das ungenau angeordnet ist.
Spielen das noch aktiv? Ja, das ist kein Event, das ist täglicher Abend RVR. Das sind aber
nicht Live-Server. Wie gesagt, das ist kein Live-Server hier. Das ist Celestius RVR.
Breshard. Hat aktuell gerade irgendwie 2000 Spieler ungefähr on. Kannst du kostenlos
runterladen, kostenlos spielen und auf geht's. Ja, aber jetzt endlich mal, dass ich was zum
Kumpelsetup sage. Also, wie gesagt, man hat acht Spieler in der Gruppe in Dark. Nicht
so dieses heute übliche von vier bis fünf. Ich glaube in WoW sind es fünf, in Final
Fantasy sind es glaube ich nur vier. Kann das sein, Leute? Dass es in Final Fantasy 14
waren es doch nur vier, oder? Zweimal DPS, einmal Support, einmal Heiler für Instanzen
und sowas. In Dark hast du acht. Das hat Vor- und Nachteile. Du kannst richtig coole Kumpelsetups
machen. Wollte ich jetzt sagen. Ja, und damit man eine ordentliche Gruppe in Dark bauen
kann, ist es halt so. Krieg grad komische Fragen per Sense. Damit man eine ordentliche
Gruppe bauen kann, braucht man in dem Spiel die passenden Chars. Sonst funktioniert's
nicht. Also ich sehe das total oft. Gerade Leute, die neu in dem Game sind, joinen die
BG. Ich hoffe unser BG-Anführer sieht mich nicht. Der regt sich immer wahnsinnig auf,
wenn Leute einfach nur rumstehen und nichts machen. Deswegen fake ich jetzt einfach mal,
dass ich was mache. Ich mache was. Ich clear die Mauer von Wachen. Ich muss so tun, als
würde ich was machen, sonst flippt unser BG-Anführer aus. Was ist denn das hier? Guck mal da. Noch
mehr Alps. Gibt keine Gegner mehr. Ach, es ist offen. Alter, geht das schnell. Also hier
geht manchmal auch richtig die Post ab in diesen Festungen, wenn halt Gegner da sind.
Aktuell sind keine Gegner da. Ich bleib einfach außen stehen und sag jetzt das, was ich eigentlich
sagen wollte. Official Server. Nein, das ist Celestios RVR. Das ist kein offizieller Server
und das ist auch kein Phönix. Phönix ist zu. Offizielles Server kannst du nicht mehr
spielen. Offizielles Server sind dead. Du brauchst und falls irgendjemand das Spiel ausprobieren
will, nur so als kleiner Ratschlag, wenn ihr eine Gruppe baut, ihr könnt die BG joinen,
ihr könnt LFG, Looking for Group und alles machen. Wenn ihr eine Gruppe baut fürs PvP,
ihr solltet gucken, dass es mindestens einen richtigen Heiler gibt in der Gruppe. Ich sehe
so viele Leute, die joinen der BG, laden random alles ein, was in der BG LFG schreibt und
wundern sich dann, dass sie permanent tot sind. 26 Monate Subscription, Alter hier. Nice,
danke für den Sub. Und wir haben natürlich das Premium Setup. Wir haben natürlich das
Premium Setup hier. Wir haben ein Minne, zwei Clarys, jetzt kommt der Hammer, vier Wizards
und ich als Hexe, also als Zork. Was besseres kannst du im Zerg nicht spielen. Wizard ist
die AE Klasse im Zerg schlechthin. Das sieht aus wie alle rennen. Guckt euch das mal, alles
echte Spieler auf einem Free-Shot von Fans betrieben. Ist das nicht heftig? Guckt euch
das mal an. Hier übrigens richtig High-Rest Bäume. Normalerweise ist hier über dem Tor
auch ein Öl, was man runterkippen kann auf das Tor, aber aktuell ist da nichts. 3. Dankeschön
für den Sub. Und in Dark muss man gucken, jede Gruppe braucht Speed und 1-2 Heiler.
Den Rest kannst du mit Damage auffüllen, aber ohne Heiler kommst du nicht aus. Und nachdem
wir jeden Abend zusammenspielen, haben wir halt auch mehr oder weniger, also ich will
nicht sagen, das Optimale ist auch sicherlich nicht das einzige, aber eines der besseren
Setups, um im Zerg zu spielen. Wir haben Speed, wir sind quasi immer vor den anderen Spielern
da, wo wir hinmüssen. Wir haben 2 Heiler und wir haben 4x AE Damage und mich für CC.
Das ist eigentlich das optimale Zerg Setup. Besser kannst du eigentlich nicht spielen.
Deswegen sind wir fast jeden Tag Top Scoreboard, ohne was dafür zu machen. Was man sagen muss,
man kann dieses Spiel auf die unterschiedlichsten Arten spielen. Guck mal, es sind ein paar
Gegner. Es sind Gegner mal da zur Abwechslung. Wahnsinn, wo sind sie denn? Zumindest haben
sie es geschafft. Da, da, guckt mal Leute, da waren 2 Gegner. Hier, guckt mal, hier,
da liegen sie. Ganze 2 Gegner haben sich in den Turm verirrt. 2 Gegner versus 100
und 180. Es ist sehr fair. Ganze 2 Gegner, Wahnsinn. Ich hoffe, es kommt gleich damit.
Das hast du 18 Jahre nicht gespielt, dann wird es Zeit. Celestius RVR, Free Shot, kannst
du kostenlos spielen. Das Game ist älter als du, ja. Ich glaube, das Game ist älter
als viele. Wenn man sich überlegt, das Game kam glaube ich 2001 raus, also sprich alle,
die von 2001 geboren sind, sind jünger als das Game. Ich habe jetzt vielleicht nicht
den glücklichsten Moment raus, ey, wenn der Fabian mitspielen würde, wäre das geilste
überhaupt, aber der wollte nicht. Das wäre das geilste überhaupt, wenn der Fabian mitspielen
würde. Du kannst immer noch ziemlich viel strafen in dem Spiel, ja. Zeige ich jetzt
aber nicht. Das Game hat schon die ein oder anderen Glitches. So, Hammer Albo und letztendlich
mal rot. Guck mal hier, fast. Fast rot wieder. Danach gehen wir ins gegnerische Grenzgebiet
und dann hoffe ich mal, dass sich uns ein paar Gegner in den Weg stellen werden, weil
so ist das ja auch nicht so spannend, wenn man einfach nur Türme und Keeps gegen Wachen
kämpft. Das ist langweilig. Das Geile an dem Game und warum ich sage, dass es das beste
PvP Spiel aller Zeiten ist, ist, weil du halt gegen echte Gegner spielst, laufend. Laufend
ist halt jetzt dumm, weil gerade ist nichts, aber ja. Naja, gucken wir mal. Genau. Wird
das Spiel auch von der Community weiterentwickelt? Ja und nein. Also am Kleint können die nichts
machen. Das ist C++, Source Code ist beim Hersteller. Aber die Serverseite entwickeln
die weiter und die haben hier Features auf dem Server, die gibt es beispielsweise auf
Live gar nicht. Du kannst zum Beispiel mit einem Kommando Waffen wechseln und sowas,
das geht auf Live nicht. Auf Live musst du jeden Scheiß aus deinem Inventar irgendwo
hinziehen. Hier kannst du ein Makro machen und solche Sachen. Also die haben noch mehr.
Die haben auch hier ganz andere Quests als auf Live. Das Leveln ist ganz anders. Also
die haben da schon viel dran gemacht. Ich brauche ein Buffbord, Leute. Ich brauche
ein Buffbord. Ich muss mal kurz ein Buffbord machen. Weg, Baby. 11 Seconds. 8, 7, ich hoffe
das Buffbord ist da nicht weg. 5, 4, 3, 2, 1. Abgebufft, sehr schön. Oh, ich nupe, ich
habe vergessen die Buff vorher wegzuklicken. Na, clever. Mach ich nachher. Richtig verkackt.
Die Buffs nicht weggeklickt. Ich hätte die Buffs wegklicken müssen, dass ich bessere
gekriegt. Weil aktuell habe ich nur 161 Decks, das ist ja nix. Hier Ghetto Buffs, Alter,
was ist das? Erstmal kurz Charge Usen. Ja, du brauchst keinen zweiten Account. Man kriegt
da, ja, du kriegst Random Buffs, aber das kommt mit dem Nachteil, dass du die halt nur
aus dem Fight beschwören kannst und Clary Buffs kannst du auf dem Clary selbst nicht
entfernen. Buffbord Buffs kannst du immer entfernen. Oh, ich hoffe gleich ein bisschen
Action. Mit echten Gegnern. Leute, wir hatten gestern die krassesten Fights überhaupt.
Ja, Decks erhöht Cast Speed. Also Geschicklichkeit ist das, was ihr für Caster braucht in dem
Decks beste. Dementsprechend, wenn ihr in Albion seid, müsst ihr eigentlich schon fast
Sarazene spielen. Also, wenn es die Klasse erlaubt für Maximum Decks. Guck, 394 Decks.
Guck mal hier, wie schnell ich jetzt cast, das flutscht richtig. Ja, so viel. Eigentlich
schon mal 45 Minuten Dark Intro gelabert. Und man erkennt übrigens schon daran, dass
das Spiel etwas komplexer ist. Du hast, guck mal, du hast allein 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
primäre Stats, Resis, Skill Points, Abilities und, passt mal auf, wenn ich euch die, und
das alle Spells, die ich habe. Hier, Spells, Spells, Spells, Spells, Spells, Spells, Spells
und Spells. Also, ich habe irgendwie einfach mal 80 Spells zur Auswahl mit der Klasse.
Man braucht davon nicht alle. Und viele sind auch Upgrade, oh nein, der BG Leader redet
über meinen Stream. Oh, er freut sich, oh. BG Leader freut sich, ok, ich hoffe, ich werde
nicht gewandt, weil ich streame. Gut, bei ihm muss man aufpassen, also eins muss ich
mal sagen, unser BG Leader, ich habe noch nie, muss ich jetzt, muss ich jetzt davor sagen,
ich habe noch nie in Dark einen besseren BG Leader gesehen als Polemo. Aber, der Kerl
hat auch seine Schattenseiten, der ist permanent am Fluchen. Wenn du nur 5 Meter, wenn du nur
5 Meter falsch läufst, scheißt er dich zusammen im Discord. Also, der übertreibt es manchmal
richtig. Wir so laufen alle wie auf Schienen, weil keiner Bock hat selbst zu laufen und
einfach nur am Leader stickt. Du kannst an, guck mal, du kannst an Leute sticken, wenn
du nicht selbst laufen willst. Guck, stick. Wenn der sich jetzt bewegt, laufe ich ihm nach,
also wenn Miezi Bombs sich bewegt, wenn er jetzt nicht einfach auf die Wache castet die
ganze Zeit, sondern sich mal bewegt, ich stick jetzt einfach ihm hier. Die haben alle keinen
Bock sich zu bewegen. Guck mal hier, er hier, er hier. Man kann daran sticken und dann läuft
man hinterher. Das ist ganz praktisch für sowas, wenn man nämlich keine Lust hat selbst
da 2 Stunden hier rumzunavigieren. Aber wohlgemerkt, sticken tun eigentlich nur die Noobs. Die
guten Leute laufen an stickt und die haben auch keine Lampe an. Gucken wir uns das ganze
mal von außen an. Keep Action ist nicht sonderlich spannend. Ja, so. Was gibt es denn sonst noch
schönes zu sagen? Wollen die uns jetzt bannen, weil ich streame oder was? What's going on?
Ja, stimmt, was ich schon die ganze Zeit erzählen wollte, also die Spells. Dass so viele Leute
das Spiel spielen, ist richtig schön. Ja, und was auch richtig nice ist, dass das so
organisiert ist. Also ich muss sagen, früher war das richtig abfuck. Früher war das richtig
abfuck in diesem Game, wenn die Leute nicht richtig organisiert waren. Hast du Delay an?
Ich hab keinen Delay an. Man kann mit Delay ziemlich kacke mit dem Chat kommunizieren.
Den Discord aus und ich habe Chat geblört. Sollte das ein Problem werden, muss ich das
nächste Mal mit Delay streamen, aber ich streame halt echt ungern mit Delay. Ihr kennt mich,
ich hab nirgendswo Delay an. Und aktuell ist es auch echt kein Problem, weil es sind keine
Gegner da. Äh, Patrick, die stream snipen. Wenn du Pech hast, stream snipen die wirklich.
Ja, vor zwei Tagen ist er richtig eskaliert. Vor zwei Tagen hat er gesagt, er wechselt
das Reich, er spielt nie wieder mit den Alps. Das ist komplett durchgedreht. Das, dass man
hier übrigens Lackspikes hat, ist ganz normal. Das Spiel hat ein bisschen Probleme, wenn
irgendwie 200 Leute mit rumzergen. Guckt euch das mal an, Leute hier. Was ein Riesenzerg.
Oh man. Ich wollte ja eigentlich ein Video auf YouTube noch dazu machen. Sollte ja eigentlich
auf YouTube ein Video zu machen. Aber ich hab mich noch nicht dazu durchgerungen. Weil,
ich weiß nicht. Die Leute wollen das glaube ich auf YouTube sich nicht angucken. Die Leute
wollen bei mir auf YouTube Technik Sachen gucken und Battlefield gucken und solche
Geschichten. Ob die Oldschool MMOs sehen wollen, weiß ich nicht. Das Wasser in dem Spiel sieht
besser aus als beim neuen Pokémon. Ja, das stimmt. Aber das ist auch keine Kunst. Das
neue Pokémon ist ja mal wieder der beste Beispiel für das Nintendo bzw. wie heißen
die? Game Freak? Heißen die Game Freak, die Nintendo Entwickler? Vor allem für Pokémon,
dass die eigentlich nix geschissen bekommen. Ich werde im Video wenn überhaupt den Fight
von gestern zeigen, weil das war wirklich heftig. Um jetzt mal die Frage zu beantworten aus
der allerersten Minute des Streams, wo ich immer noch nicht darauf eingegangen bin nach
über einer Stunde oder fast einer Stunde, ist die Spells. Ich sag mal kurz was zu, während
wir hier das Keeprain. Ich muss nix machen. Es sind gerade mega krass viele Alps. Im Prinzip
kann ich AFK mitlaufen und das geht alles von alleine. Es sind halt einfach gerade 200
Alps hier am Start. Die überrollen eh alles. Guckt euch das mal an. Meine Güte. Musst du
nicht irgendwas buffen, healen oder damage machen? Doch. Aber es sind keine Gegner da.
Es sind bloß leere Festungen. Wartet mal bis die Gegner kommen und die Gegner werden kommen.
Vielleicht habe ich sogar mit meinem Stream ein bisschen Einfluss, dass sie sich denken
alter die Alps die wollen wir erst recht wegficken jetzt. Man kann übrigens für alle wo es
ruckelt kann man sagen Effects none. Dann rendert das Spiel keine Effekte mehr und es läuft
ein bisschen flüssiger. Wir wollen hier die komplette Palette Dark Effects haben. Warum
das leere Festungen sind nur weil keine Gegner aufgetaucht sind. Die Gegner haben alle Festungen
eingenommen und sind jetzt nicht da. Ich stelle mich jetzt mal kurz nebenbei hin und
sag mal was zu den zu den Spells, weil das wurde die erste Minute schon gefragt. Ich
habe jetzt eine Stunde rumgelaber und nichts passiert. Also wie gesagt, ich spiele Sorg
auf Deutsch hieß das in dem Spiel hieß das Hexe beziehungsweise. Wie haben sie das auf?
Wie ist eigentlich in dem Spiel Deutsche Hexer wahrscheinlich dann? Keine Ahnung. Weiß gar
nicht. Wie hieß dann wie hieß wie ist dann Sorcerer auf Deutsch in dem Spiel Hexe und
Hexer wahrscheinlich also nichts mit Witcher zu tun. Das ist eh Dark wurde eh relativ
frei übersetzt. Also zu den Spells wie gesagt, ich spiele die Haupt CC Klasse in Albion,
das heißt ich bin eigentlich dafür zuständig, wenn denn mal Gegner kommen sollten dafür
zu sorgen, dass sie nichts machen können und um das zu und ich kann übrigens auch ganz
gut Damage machen. So damit das Ganze funktioniert. Übrigens das hier ist die Lebensanzeige von
meiner Gruppe, also Leben, Ausdauer und Mana und ihr seht eigentlich alles top. Außer
Cops, der hat keinen Mana mehr, was auch immer Cops gerade macht, ich weiß nicht. Wahrscheinlich
hat er das Tor genugt. So also zu meinen Spells. Warum werden Leute gebannt? Was habe ich verpasst
im Chat? Aber ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon recht, ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon recht.
So zu meinen Spells, was man als Hexe so machen kann. Das ist jetzt so ein Beispiel, wie gesagt
das Spiel hat, ich zeig's euch mal, Schaarplaner. Das Spiel, das sind alle Klassen, die dieses
Spiel hat. Also es ist wirklich in Dark, es ist für jeden was dabei. Du hast hier allein
schon ach so die Klassen sind nicht nach Reiche sortiert. Wie viel ist denn das hier? 1, 2,
3, 4, mal 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11. Was ist das 44 oder so? Irgendwie 44 Klassen,
also hier ist wirklich für jeden was dabei. Und damit ich als Hexe in Albion meinen Job
machen kann. Ah 45, unten war auch noch einer. Habe ich verschiedene Spells. Also ich versuche
euch das mal kurz zu erklären. In Ermangelung von Gegnern. Das kann ich euch gerade nicht
zeigen, weil gerade keine Gegner da sind. Ich hoffe, die kommen gleich und machen hier
Gangbang von allen Seiten. Also ich habe zwei Damage Spells. Ich muss ja auch Gegner killen
können. Und der ist sogar relativ gut. Der 3-Shotted Gegner, gegnerische Caster. Ich
habe einen Root. Wenn ich einen Root auf den Gegner zaubere, dann kann er sich nicht mehr
bewegen. Ich habe einen AE-Root. 3 Mal dürft ihr euch raten, was ein AE-Root macht. Natürlich,
das kann nicht mehr laufen. Das ist halt eine Gruppe von Gegnern. Und ich habe einen Single
und einen AE. So eine Art Stun ist das. Es ist nicht wirklich ein Stun, aber ich kann
euch das nicht besser erklären, weil... Was ist in der BG los? Weil die meisten Leute
damit nichts anfangen können. Also ich kann die Gegner hier zum Beispiel für Stun, der
durch Schaden aufgehoben wird. Das trifft es gut, genau. Es ist ein Stun, der durch Schaden
aufgehoben wird. Die Gegner in einem Radius von 350 Einheiten kann ich die Gegner für
46 Sekunden betäuben. Wohlgemäht 46 Sekunden. Also wie gesagt, in Daox seid ihr fucked,
wenn ihr im CC steht und nichts dagegen macht. Ihr habt gelitten. Ihr seid den ganzen Fight
einfach nicht in der Lage, was zu machen. Es gibt zum Glück genug, was man machen kann
gegen CC in Daox. Also ich kann quasi hier in einem Bereich von 350 Einheiten 46 Sekunden
lang die Gegner betäuben. Der wird aber durch Schaden gebrochen. Das habe ich noch Single
und da geht da eine Minute 20. Das CC wird durch Resistenzen reduziert. Man kann das
mit einer RA ausschalten. Man kann Spells casten, die Teammates quasi entbetäuben und
sowas. Aber das sind so die Hauptspells, die man eigentlich als Hexe hat. AE Hut und ich
nenne es mal AE Stun. Du hast noch ein paar Debuffs. Debuffs für weniger Leben für die
Gegner, weniger Geschicklichkeit für die Gegner. Und das sind meine Realm Abilities. Das ist
das, was ich mir von den Punkten kaufe, die ich durchs PvP bekomme. Zum Beispiel sowas
wie Concentration. Da kann ich dann zweimal casten hiermit, ohne dass ich unterbrochen
werden kann und sowas. Also es ist relativ komplex. Du checkst gar nichts. Das macht
nichts. Du kannst es nicht checken. Das ist nicht dafür gedacht. Das sind 10 Minuten
zu checken. Geht nicht. Aber das wichtigste ist, wenn man Gegner sieht, gefühlt ist das
seitlich schneller als geradeaus. Ja, das ist Dauerklogik. Wenn man Gegner sieht, muss
ich folgendes machen. Ich muss die Gegner anklicken, Paste drücken und ganz wie verrückt
das hier hemmern. Und dann stehen die Gegner erstmal. Und wenn ich das gut gemacht habe,
dann überrennt der Alp zack die Gegner. Das ist mein Job. Mein Job ist gar nicht so
sehr Damage zu machen. Wobei ich auch relativ gut Damage machen kann. Aber die beste Damageklasse
im Spiel ist meiner Meinung nach ebisart. Nicht nur in Albion, im ganzen Game. Ja,
das oben links. Das hier sind Buffs, die ich gerade habe. In der Mitte. Und das hier ist
meine Skill-Leiste. Also das hier sind meine Skills an Zauber, Abilities und alles was es
so gibt. Ihr seht mich relativ wenig auf die Leiste drücken. Das liegt daran, weil ich
alles Wichtige auswendig weiß, wo das ist. Und das auf Tasten gelegt habe. Also eines
der sichersten Zeichen in Dauerk, dass du ein Ober, ein Ultra-Noob bist. Ein Hyper-Noob.
Ups, falsche Sim-Mode. Ein Hyper-Noob ist, wenn du so spielst. Guck mal. Wenn man so
spielst. Aha. Target. Target. Target. Zauber. DD. DD. DD. Das kannst du vergessen. Also
das ist das sicherste Zeichen, dass der Ober-Noob in dem Spiel ist. In Wirklichkeit machst du
es so. Guck. Tap, Face, DD, DD. So funktioniert das. Jetzt hat er den gecharmed. Gegner,
Dings, Damage. Guck mal, jetzt kann ich es euch mal zeigen. Guck mal hier, das sind Mops,
die laggen as fuck rum, weil der Server überfordert ist mit 200 Alps im Grenzgebiet hier gerade.
Guck mal, jetzt. Guck mal, jetzt habe ich ihn CC'd. Jetzt schläft er. Jetzt macht
er nichts mehr. Und sobald einer Damage macht auf den, wacht er wieder auf. Guck.
Ist das prüfungsrelevant? Alles prüfungsrelevant hier im Stream. Es ist wieder Nacht. Na super,
ich mache die Lampe an, weil ihr seid. Ja und Hexe ist by the way eines der, äh, und
Hexe ist by the way eines der opesten, ähm, Klassen in diesem ganzen Game, weil du hast
quasi alles. Du hast quasi alles. Du hast Damage, du hast CC und du hast Speed, das
heißt man rennt auch noch schneller, was ich vergessen habe zu casten. Guckt euch, also
das ist echt heftig, aber wie so vieles in Dark eigentlich nicht so OP, wie es auf den
ersten Blick aussehen mag. Äh, Chet sagt, ich spielte ein, was? Was hast du gespielt?
Ein, ein was? Was ist denn ein, ein, ein, was ist denn ein Tree Age? Also die Abkürzung,
ich dachte eigentlich, ich kenne alle Abkürzung. Kommt mal Leute, Albion ist wieder rot. Oh,
wir porten. Wo porten wir hin? Das müsst ihr mir sagen, Chet. Wohin? Wir porten. Ach,
Tree Speck Heiler. Ah, Tree Speck Heiler, verstehe. Wir porten Benno. Okay, wir porten
Benno, Teleport. Rammen kaufen in Benno. Nice. Nice Rammen Action. Vielleicht fahren wir
jetzt ja mal mit dem Schiff irgendwo hin, dass wir auch mal ein paar Gegner killen können.
Es ist so heftig zu sehen, wenn man sich überlegt, das Spiel ist 20 Jahre alt und es ist ein
Free-Shart von Fans betrieben und es sind gerade, gerade, pass mal auf. Oh, wir fahren
nach Hip Boats, jawoll. Es sind gerade 2000 Leute und davon sind es 800 Leute oder so
im Grenzgebiet. Richtig heftig und es ist wirklich so, wie es im Titel steht, RVR beziehungsweise
PvP technisch, es gibt kein besseres Spiel. Es ist das beste PvP Spiel, wenn man MMOs
sucht. Das kann man jetzt nicht vergleichen mit Battlefield oder sowas. Es ist quasi der
Urvater von, ja, es ist quasi das, was Guild Wars sich abgeguckt hat zum Teil. Nur, bin
ich im richtigen Boot? Ja, hu, zum Glück. Nur, es wurde nie erreicht. Es wurde nie erreicht
in Dark. Guckt euch mal an, der Zerg ist on the move, ja. Die Mids machen ihren Drachen
Raid. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was mit den Mids los ist. Die machen gefühlt alle 30
Minuten Drachen Raid. Wenn euch das ganz übrigens gefällt, wenn ihr wollt, ich kann gerne,
wir können gerne irgendwie so mal einen, einmal in der Woche Dark-Abend machen oder sowas.
Den Leuten in-Game gefällt es auch, dass ich streme, so wie es aussieht. Was euch jetzt
vielleicht aufgefallen ist, wir sind jetzt quasi geografisch eher so nach Irland gefahren
gerade. Also das ist so ein mittelalterliches Irland angelehnt hier. Das sieht jetzt alles
anders aus. Es ist grüner, die Bäume sehen anders aus und das ist auch was, was Dark wirklich
besser hinbekommen hat, als jedes andere Game, was ich kenne. Egal, was du für ein Reich
spielst, also ob du jetzt Albion, Midgard oder Hibernia spielst, das sieht komplett
anders aus. Wohingegen Midgard halt Schnee ist, Hibernia ist alles grün, Albion ist so
ein bisschen dazwischen, es hat alles eigenen Charakter und sieht alles anders aus. Guckt
euch mal das Grenzgebiet hier an jetzt, es sieht komplett anders aus als das andere.
Gut, ihr könnt es jetzt vielleicht schlecht einschätzen, aber wenn ihr euch das ein paar
mal angeguckt habt, wird euch das wahrscheinlich auffallen. So many Alps, where are Hibs? Ja,
das frage ich mich auch. Oh, wir sind nicht energisch genug an den Toren, Begeli da ist
nicht zufrieden mit uns. Wir kriegen Ärger. Ja, übrigens, das ist in Dark normal, dass
du solche Wände hier hochlaufen kannst. Guckt es euch mal an, das ist normal, easy. Einfach
mal die Wand hochgelaufen, kein Problem. Ja, da merkst du dem Spiel schon ein bisschen
den Alter an. Mein In-Game-Chat sagt gerade, voll Maximum Epic Pok Efforts sollen wir
jetzt geben an den Türen, alles klar. Ach ja, und übrigens, wenn ihr das Spiel ausprobieren
wollt und das zum ersten Mal startet, werdet ihr feststellen, das Spiel sieht bei euch
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser aus wie bei mir, weil ich habe alte Models und die
neuen Models sind deutlich detailreicher, aber ich finde sie hässlich im Vergleich
zu den alten. Einfach mal mitten in die Mops gerannt. So, und was euch vielleicht auch
auffällt, das hier ist jetzt ein Keep, also eine Festung in Hip, die sieht komplett anders
aus als die bei uns. Also es hat alles seinen eigenen Stil und seine eigene Optik in dem
Spiel, je nachdem wo du gerade bist. Alter, wie es ruckelt, der Server kommt nicht hinterher.
So, ich hoffe echt, es kommen jetzt mal ein paar Gegner, weil ganz ehrlich, wenn keine
Gegner kommen, habt ihr vielleicht die Chance was zu sehen, was es nicht so oft gibt, nämlich
das wir die Relikte klauen. Also es muss ja, vielleicht mal so, man könnte sich jetzt
fragen, falls sich das jemand von euch gefragt hat, werde ich es jetzt beantworten, warum
man überhaupt ins Grenzgebiet gehen sollte und PvP machen. Erste ist natürlich klar,
weil es Bock macht, weil es der Kerninhalt des Spiels ist, aber es hat natürlich auch
ein Ziel oder ein System dahinter. Jedes Reich hat zwei Relikte. Albion hat, lass mal überlegen,
da auch Geschichte, kenne ich mich nicht wirklich aus. Albion hat glaube ich Merlins Stab und
Excalibur, Midgard hat Thor's Hammer und Ingnen, keine Ahnung und Hibernia hat einen Speer und
ich glaube Ingnen Handschuh oder sowas, keine Ahnung. Jedes Reich hat zwei Relikte. So und
wenn man die Gegner richtig fertig gemacht hat im Grenzgebiet, also sprich nahezu alle
Fästungen erobert hat, dann, ich zeige euch das mal, hier im Grenzgebiet, also wenn wir
jetzt beispielsweise diese Versorgungslinie an Keeps erobert haben, dann geht hier hinten
das, dort wo das Relikt gelagert ist auf und dann können wir das Relikt den Gegnern abnehmen
und auf live war das so, wenn man das Relikt des Gegners hat, hat man 10% extra Damage
bekommen, je nachdem was man erobert hat. 10% extra Nahkampfdamage oder 10% extra Caster
Damage und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, oder waren es sogar 20%? Nein, 10% pro Relikt und
wenn man beide Relikte hatte, 20%, so war es auf live. Und wenn ihr euch überlegt, ich
hätte oder die Caster haben 20% extra Damage, das ist nicht ohne. Ja, bei den Mids sind
so viele ab Drachenrate, ich weiß auch nicht. Übrigens, jetzt ist es schon weg, hier oben
ist immer so ein Öl überm Tor. Wenn man da rein rennt und man kriegt das auf den Kopf
geschürtet, Instant Death. Action Inc. sagt mein Chat. Okay, vielleicht gibt es gleich
ein paar Fights. Schauen wir mal, passiert hier irgendwas? Aha, gucken wir mal. Ihr
müsstet dabei sein. Ich werde euch den Discord nicht anmachen, weil Discord ist zu intern
die Information, da jetzt das zu streamen, aber ich muss immer so lachen. Unser BG Leader
flippt immer so aus, wenn Gegner am Start sind, das ist der Wahnsinn. Der schreit immer
herum. Ich muss mich immer so zusammenreißen, ich muss immer so lachen. Der eskaliert immer
komplett. Für was steht BG? Battle Group steht BG. Guck mal, normalerweise sollte man
hier jetzt einen Boss sehen, man sieht gar nichts, außer Pets. Also wir haben gerade
eigentlich den da gekillt, aber man hat es halt nicht gesehen, weil 200 Alps im Turm.
Es ist eh, ich liebe MMO Drama. Ich liebe MMO Drama. Jemand klaut den anderen die Mops.
Riesentrama. Jemand killt jemand anderes und addet in den Fight. Riesentrama. Erklär
mal 8 vs. 8. Hm, was soll ich da erklären? 8 vs. 8 bedeutet eine Gruppe vs. eine andere
Gruppe. Möglichst ohne Ads. Und ich war früher, ich muss sagen, ich hab mich um 180 Grad
gewandelt in diesem Spiel. Ich war früher der übelste 8 vs. 8 Verfechter. Ich hab
die ganzen Zerger und BG Leute immer ausgelacht, so nach dem Motto H0 Noobs learn to play und
so ein Shit. Und heute finde ich ganz gut. Heute join ich in die BG, zerge ein bisschen
rum, kill paar getenerische BGs und freu mich. Nix mehr 8 vs. 8. Da bin ich jetzt mit 37
zu alt für. Und was ich witzig finde ist, das ist auch so ein typisches Ding. Ich weiß
nicht was, was es mit Dark auf sich hat. Ich weiß nicht was es mit Dark auf sich hat, aber
es gibt so ein paar Leute, die spielen das so richtig, als geht es um was. Was ja okay
ist. Da sag ich ja gar nichts dagegen. Man kann ja auch MMOs ein bisschen ernster spielen.
Aber die machen so auf Ultra Elite Club immer. Und die sind heute alle so alt wie ich. Die
sind auch alle 35 plus oder so und haben das Spiel damals schon gesuchtet. Aber verhalten
sich in dem Spiel wie, als wären sie wieder 15. Ich weiß nicht, was mit manchen Leuten
los ist in Dark. Aber falls ihr das Spiel ausprobieren solltet, lasst euch nicht so
sehr davon abschrecken, wenn es so möchtegern Elite Leute gibt, die euch erklären wollen,
dass alles suckt und keine Ahnung, dass ihr Scheiße seid und das 8 vs. 8 das einzig wahre
ist und sowas in der Richtung. Ich war früher genauso. Wie gesagt, ich hab damals vor Players
geflamed gegen Leute, die Zerg spielen. Alter, wie es ruckelt, man. 180 Alps zu viel. Aber
heute ganz entspannt WG. Boah ey, ich kann da nicht hingucken. Mein Rechner kackt ab,
wenn ich hier in den Turm mit den Effekten gucke. Boah, guckt euch mal an, Alter, wie
das ruckelt. Oh, sind ein paar Gegner mal da zur Abwechslung. Oh, Gegner. Gegner, Gegner.
Das hab ich gar nicht aufgepasst. Oder doch nicht? Nö, doch nicht. Keine Gegner. Ich
hab gedacht da hinten kommen Hips um die Ecke, machen sie nicht. Langweilig. Zu viele Alps
am Start. Oh, guck mal, da unten gibt's Gegner. Da, guckt euch das mal an. Gegner. Gegner.
Speedbrechen. Komm, Alps, zergt sie um. Jawoll, gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm. Drauf.
Oh, wenn das unser, wenn das Polemo sieht. Stop chasing Peanuts. Wenn das Polemo sieht,
er flippt aus. Okay, sie sind entkommen. Keine Chance gehabt zu erwischen. Ach ja, eine Sache
muss ich euch an der Stelle auch noch erklären. Warum die Gegner so schnell waren, liegt daran,
normalerweise musst du, wenn du ins PvP gehst, ansonsten wirst du einfach nur die ganze Zeit
zerstört. Du musst eine Klasse mit Speed mitnehmen. In Albion ist das hier der Mindestsänger,
der kann so einen Speedsong spielen auf seiner Trommel, der trommelt da so vor sich hin und
dann dadurch den alle so furchtbar motiviert, dass sie schneller rennen. In Midgard haben
sie den Skalde für Speedsong und Bade in Hip. Und deswegen sind die so schnell. Aber sobald
der Fight losgeht, tropft man aus dem Speed raus. Bevor Hip BG ist coming, schreibt gerade
einer im Chat. Okay. Anscheinend sind Hips am Start. Gleich gibt's Action. Endlich. Mit
einer Alp BG von 232 Leute in der BG. Ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich habe noch nie seit ich
dauernd spiele so viele Leute in der BG gesehen. Noch nie. Das ist Premiere. Selbst gestern
war mir nicht so viel. 232. So, ich muss jetzt in die Ramme, sonst kriege ich Ärger. Was
ist Chat? Hey Max, wer bietet noch mal einen Server Service an? Ah, du meinst meinen Sponsor
Hezner? Ja, das ist abgelaufen. Das ist abgelaufen. Mein Hezner-Sponsoring ist abgelaufen. Da muss
ich erst warten, was wir dieses Jahr machen. Hohe Suchtgefahr bei dem Game? Ja, übertrieben
hohe Suchtgefahr. Also bei mir ist es so, ich habe zuletzt 2010 live gespielt. Also auf
dem Live-Server, auf dem offiziellen Server. 2010 und seitdem immer mal wieder. Ich habe
Origins gespielt, ich habe Phönix gespielt, ich habe jetzt Celestius gespielt und jedes
Mal wenn ich dauernd anfange, suchte ich das 2-3 Monate am Stück durch bis RR 10 11. Ich
kann hier anders bei dem Game. Ich gebe zu, wenn das jetzt das erste Mal ist, dass ihr
das Game seht. Und ihr seht einen Haufen 230 Alps, die Keep-Tore auf. Ein Gegner, ein Gegner,
gib ihm. Ein ganzer. Okay, er ist down. Der hat nicht damit gerechnet, dass gleich 200
Alps durch das Tor. Guckt euch das mal an. Was eine Welle, was eine Welle hier durchrennt.
Noch ein Gegner. Der hat nicht damit gerechnet, dass hier die riesen Alpwelle der Alp Tsunami
am Start ist. Tja, wer ist es denn hier? Ja, Varano, damit hat er nicht gerechnet. Jetzt
fangen die Mits an BG zu bauen, ja endlich, dann gibt's Action. Was sind hier draußen?
Was ist hier? Sind hier Gegner? Sind hier Gegner? Was sind Gegner? Darf ich jetzt raus,
wenn ich Livestreame? Ich kriege Ärger von Polemo, wenn ich hier rausgehe. Geh mir, Gegner.
Peanuts chasen. Gegner tot. Hat sich erledigt. Oh guck mal, noch ein Gegner. Mit Face Shift
haben, deswegen nimmt er keinen Damage. Jetzt ist er down. Ein ganzer Gegner, Wahnsinn.
Hast du ein paar Stellenanzeigen für neues Video? Ja, aber ich hab doch erst eins gemacht.
Warum stirbt meine Gruppe halb? Was ist da los? Was ist da los? Okay, ich geh schon in
die Ramme. Gut, das Keep ist ein bisschen härter. Ich hab euch ja am Anfang erzählt, man kann
mit ner Gilde diese Festung claimen und wenn man die claimt, kann man die upgraden. Und
dieses Keep hier ist, guck mal, ich klick das jetzt mal an, da seht ihr, das ist Dun & Get,
so heißt die Festung hier und die ist lila. Lila bedeutet höchstes Level in dem Fall.
Die Keeps können grün, blau, gelb, orange, rot oder lila sein und lila ist, sprich das
ist höchstes Level. Beeinfacht erklärt. Höchstes Level heißt, die Tore halten mehr
aus, die Wachen sind stärker, der Lord ist stärker und es sieht ein bisschen anders
aus. Das ist glaub ich auch größer, hier oben auf den Zinnen drauf. Achja, das Spiel
hat übrigens auch Belagerungswaffen, so Trebuchets und Katapulte, weil hier oben drauf sind mal
ganz gerne Gegner und die könnten einen ja quasi bashen, ohne dass man was dagegen machen
kann, aber man kann einfach reinballern mit Belagerungszeug. Also ihr seht, vieles was
ihr von moderneren Games kennt, kommt aus Dark, was PvP angeht und es wurde noch nie
so gut umgesetzt, nie wieder so gut umgesetzt. Spaziergang, ja. Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich
euch nachher mal so ein bisschen noch die Klassen und Kategorien des Kipps zeigen für
Leute, die vielleicht Bock haben, sich das Game mal anzugucken. Also ich kann es euch
nur empfehlen, wer Bock hat auf MMOs, wo tatsächlich das M noch großgeschrieben wird, also MMOs
nicht für Massively Multiplayer, online, online ist es klar, aber wer wirklich Wert
drauf legt, dass das M in einem MMO großgeschrieben wird, der sollte sich das wirklich mal angucken.
Also wer auf PvP steht, in dem Fall ist es R4R, weil es mehrere Reiche gibt, ohne Friendly
Player, wer auf PvP steht und wer mag, dass man mit vielen anderen Leuten zusammenspielt
ist hier eigentlich genau richtig. Warum ist der Chat geblurrt, weil ich nicht Infos leaken
will? Guckt man sieht es, der Lord hält deutlich mehr aus, weil das Keep hochgelevelt ist.
Oh noch ein Gegner, aber es ist richtig Spaziergang, ich weiß wirklich nicht, wo die Gegner alle
sind. Gestern 200 Leute, 100 Leute vs 100 Leute vs 100 Leute und heute, ja ich habe
extra gewartet, bis wir anfangen richtig, jetzt schießen sie auf uns von da unten,
big brain time. Habe ich gedacht es gibt ein bisschen Action, aber nein. Ja Foxy hat Recht,
er schreibt gerade im Chat, es ist ein bisschen viel, es ist ziemlich komplex und es dauert
ein bisschen bis man dahinterblickt, ja das stimmt. Ich hoffe wir haben bald mal ordentlich
einen Fight und ich kann leider kein Discord anmachen, es ist einfach zu lustig, teilweise
wie unser BG Anführer abgeht bei Ink, also so nennt man das in dem Spiel, wenn Gegner
auftauchen. Riesenalpzerg, Riesenmassive, ach guck mal Turtle am Start, Wave.
64 Kills in 2 Stunden, nur ja das ist viel zu wenig, nur mal best game ever, aber best
game ever, ja so siehts aus. Torpedo, gestern hatten wir, also wir haben jetzt in 2 Stunden
es gerade mal geschafft 64 Kills zu machen, gestern hatten wir nach 2 Stunden 550 Kills,
also gestern war absolut insane, aber irgendwie haben die Gegner heute kein Bock, wir rennen
einfach durchs Grenzgebiet und nichts taucht auf an Gegnern, die wollen nicht, dass wir
mal was ordentliches sehen im Stream. Wenn wir hier ordentliche Fights zeigen, hat das
Spiel morgen 500 Spieler mehr, hoffe ich, vielleicht kann ich ja ein bisschen was zu
beitragen, weil ehrlich gesagt, das ist nicht das spannendste, also ab und zu mal ein bisschen
RPs machen mit Keeps Raiden ist ja in Ordnung, aber leere Keeps Raiden ohne Gegner ist ziemlich
langweilig, ja Mids bauen ihre BG, das dauert immer ewig, aber Hips müssen die fetten,
die Sache ist halt die, wenn die Gegner wirklich nicht ihr Grenzgebiet verteidigen, dann nehmen
wir einfach das Relikt mit und dann seht ihr vielleicht mal ein Relikt Raid, was man nicht
so oft sieht in dem Spiel, also wenn die Hips jetzt wirklich sagen, nö wir haben keinen
Bock, wir machen nichts, dann brauchen wir noch glaube ich das Keep und ich glaube man
braucht das, das und das, ich check das System bis heute nicht, man braucht glaube ich 3
oder 4 Keeps in der richtigen Reihenfolge, dass man das Relikt nehmen kann, ich check
nicht, wie das funktioniert, Low IQ, das habe ich noch nie kapiert, wie das genau funktioniert,
ach unser Relikt liegt hier unten drinnen, ja das geht natürlich auch, dann reicht es,
wenn wir die Festung einnehmen, aber spätestens hier müssen Gegner kommen, also wenn wir direkt
vor der Festung mit dem Relikt drinnen stehen, da können die nichts anderes machen, als
endlich mal anzurücken, da ist doch, da ist was, guck mal da, ein Gegner, aber ich kann
da nicht alleine hinterher, oh da kommen welche, da kommen welche, ink, ink, ink, Leute, Gegners,
Gegners, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Speedwarp stellen, die rennen schon weg, guck mal die
rennen schon weg, sie rennen schon weg, ich fasse es nicht, ja ihr seht ihn hinter dem
Baum nicht, aber der steht jetzt, guck mal da ist er, ich habe ihn betäubt und jetzt
nuke ich ihn um und jetzt ist er down und ich habe immer noch keine, ich war immer noch
nicht beim Buffbot, ich fasse es nicht, Alter ich brauche Buffs, Speck, Dex, Dex please,
ich muss, ich muss gebufft werden, ich war immer noch nicht beim Buffbot, ich habe es
vergessen, normalerweise caste ich deutlich schneller, guckt euch das mal an, die armen
Gegners, guckt euch das mal an wie sie rennen, warum wir langsamer sind, weil die Gegner
Speedwarps stellen können, das wäre sonst mega unfair, sonst würdest du mit 200, sonst
würdest du, oh oh Watchtower, oh nein, oh nein, Biggie Bunn incoming, großer Anführer hat
gesagt wir müssen zum Watchtower, dann muss, ok, komplett random, ich habe keine Ahnung
wo hier irgendwas abgeht, jeder rennt in eine andere Richtung, ich renne einfach meinem
Group Leader hinterher, da kann ich mich rausreden, das liegt nicht an mir, ja also folgendermaßen
entweder wenn man selbst Damage bekommt oder Damage macht, sehr gut erstmal an Baum, wenn
man selber Damage macht oder Damage bekommt, geht das Speed aus oder wenn die Gegner einen
Speedwarp stellen, so was hier, haben die Gegner auch, dann hat man kein Speed, das
ist aber auch insofern ganz wichtig, damit man nicht so sehr überrascht werden kann,
wenn wir das jetzt nicht gestellt hätten, könnte uns zum Beispiel eine 5er Gruppe,
könnte uns beispielsweise 5 Gruppen von der Seite mit Speed übelst wegficken, die rennen
in uns rein, Aes dann und Bomben alles weg, deswegen ist wichtig, dass man seine Speedwarps
setzt, dass das eben nicht passiert, ach komm mal da sind Gegner, oh gar nicht, zu wenige
Gegner sind da hinten, ok Schnors, guckt euch das mal an, wollen die jetzt wirklich
drauf, das sind nicht mal ansatzweise so viel wie wir, das sind vielleicht 40 und wir sind
180, oh Kops, warum ist Kops tot, das macht nichts, Kops stirbt öfter mal, muss man sich
keine Gedanken zumachen, also Kops stirbt jeden Abend irgendwie so 5, 6 mal, das ist
ein Feature, jetzt sind sie weg, so aber ihr habt die Gegner da hinten gesehen, hätten
wir nicht unsere Speedwarps hier hingestellt und hätten nicht dahin geguckt, hätten die
uns jetzt voll in die Flanke rennen können und ihr werdet es vielleicht gleich sehen,
wenn ein Fight ist, also wenn man falsch steht, Positioning ist in Daug mit Abstand das wichtigste,
wenn man falsch steht, man ist instant tot, nicht weil man so wenig aushält, sondern weil
einfach so viele Gegner Damage auf einen machen und gerade als Hexe muss man gucken, dass man
ordentlich positioniert ist.
Es gibt ein paar Schlüsselklassen in dem Spiel, wo man, gerade wenn man mit weniger
Leuten gegen, jetzt nicht, also nicht gerade bei 100 vs. 100, bei 100 vs. 100 gewinnt in
der Regel der, der mehr Spieler hat, aber gerade wenn man, sag mal mal, irgendwie 4-5 Leute
gegen 4-5 Leute kämpft, es gibt so ein paar Schlüsselklassen, wo man wirklich auf Zack
sein muss, das ist in Albion zum Beispiel, Clary und Hexe, da musst du halt einfach gucken,
dass du aufmerksam bist und ich hab so oft verkackt schon, dass ich nicht gesehen hab,
wenn Gegner kommen oder sowas, dann bist du halt direkt tot.
In Midgard ist es eindeutig Heiler, wo du aufpassen musst, wenn du in Midgard als Heiler
nicht aufpasst, ist es halt auch vorbei.
Es hat jedes Reich so zwei Schlüsselklassen, würde ich sagen, die gerade am Anfang von
einem Fight mega aufpassen müssen.
Come on guys, ok, was soll ich machen?
Ok, es werden Tactics kommuniziert im Chat, da sag ich jetzt nix zu, guck mal, Pilze,
übrigens eine Sache, die ihr als, egal ob ihr Albion oder Midgard spielt, eine Sache,
die ihr hassen werdet, sind Pilze, guckt euch mal an, Pilze, die Hips können Pilze stellen
und diese Pilze sind mit Abstand, ohne Scheiß, mit Abstand das nervigste, was es in diesem
Spiel gibt.
Pilze ist das Schlimmste, wie ich ja vorhin versucht hab zu erklären, ist das halt so ein
bisschen aufgeteilt, quasi Hips sind so die Naturliebhaber, Midgard sind eher so die Nahkampf
orientierten Nordmänner, Albion ist so alles irgendwie ein bisschen, so und in Hips gibt
es eine Klasse, die kann Pilze stellen, best game ever, so siehts aus und in Hips gibt
es eine Klasse, der Animist, der kann Pilze stellen und die Pilze sind über abfuck, es
gibt Damage Pilze, es gibt Root Pilze, Root Pilze sind das Schlimmste, bekommt das Spiel
noch Updates?
Ja, ich spiel auf nem FreeShart, dort gibt es jeden Tag, also die haben Agile Entwicklung
verstanden bei Celestius, es gibt jeden Tag nen Patch mit Fixes und den ein oder anderen
neuen Sagen, Sachen, jeden Tag, wir reden hier von einem fernbetriebenen FreeShart für
nen Game von 2001 und ich glaub Server, Nodes, ich weiß es nicht, wie man sich die, Nodes,
was Nodes, was Patch Nodes, Patch Nodes, ich weiß es nicht, Info, es gab nen Kommando,
wie man sich das anzeigen lassen kann, Leute warum sind wir alleine, wo ist der Zerg, wo
sind die alle hin, das hab ich mal kurz nicht aufgepasst und auf einmal alle weg, gucken
wir mal auf die Karte, ach da, ach da ist der Zerg, ok, ach Zauberin hat LD, ok, wahrscheinlich
das Game gecrashed, ach Server News ist es, Server News, Server News ist es, ja guck mal,
es gibt jeden Tag einen neuen Patch, der ist von heute, mit Bug Fixes und neuen Kleinigkeiten,
manchmal auch größeren Sachen, ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, ein fernbetriebener Server
schafft es gleichzeitig Features und Bug Fixes zu entwickeln, was wozu DICE bei einem Multimillionen
Franchise nicht in der Lage ist, ich geb zu es ist ein bisschen Äpfel mit Birnen verglichen,
aber trotzdem, oh Zauberin dead, dachte Elinaras ist immer dead, Zauberin auch dead, na gut,
dann warten wir mal ab, ich hoffe, ich hoffe es kommen jetzt ein paar Gegner, eine Sache
die in Dark, gerade wenn man BG, PvP spielt, halt ein bisschen doof ist, Zauberin ist jetzt
gestorben und wir haben keine Chance die zu holen, da müsstest du durchs halbe Grenzgebiet
rennen jetzt wieder, zurück und wirst wahrscheinlich, wenn du mit nur 5 Leuten unterwegs bist,
glanlos abgefarmt, guck mal Gegner, aber Gegner im Boot kann man nicht angreifen, es befindet
sich auch gerade ein Server in Entwicklung im vierten, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen,
wie wollen sie das denn machen, die können ja kleinzeitig nichts reinpatchen, also was
hab ich gesagt, wenn man nicht von der Seite weggeflankt werden will, immer schön, immer
schön Speed Warps setzen, Speed Warps, sonst gibt's Gachibas von der Seite gleich, ich
sollte mich vielleicht mal irgendwann buffen, ich renn die ganze Zeit, ich renn die ganze
Zeit ohne Buffs rum, das ist richtig dumm, bis Band, ich stell mir jetzt nen Buffbott,
den ich mach jetzt Buffs weg, so Buffs weg, Buffbott, 69 Sekunden bis Buffbott, come on,
jetzt hab ich gar keine Buffs, auch geil, top, sehr gut, ich brauch unbedingt ordentliche
Buffs, dadurch, dass es hier Buff NPCs gibt, haben die Clary alle nur so Ghetto Buffs gespeckt,
da ist Tamek, Dankeschön, ja und neben allem dem, was ich euch erzählt habe, selbst wenn
man diese Sachen alle drin hat, hat Dark halt, wenn man wirklich seine Klasse gut spielen
will, noch super viele Feinheiten zu bieten, zum Beispiel, nur ein Beispiel, diese Reichsfähigkeit,
die ich hier habe, resette zum Beispiel den Immun-Timer für meinen Rute, also ich kann
Gegner routen, in diese Fähigkeit reinhauen und sie dann nochmal routen für ne Minute,
das sind alles so Sachen, das kommt, wenn man das Spiel mit einer Weile spielt, wenn man
neu anfängt, muss man, ich würd mich jetzt, also wenn jemand wirklich Bock hat, das Spiel
auszuprobieren, auch wenn ich zugebe, das ist relativ langweilig gerade, ach guck mal,
da steht ein Gegner, Pog, weil wir halt einfach nur leere Keeps erobern, wenn jemand wirklich
mal Bock hat, das Ganze auszuprobieren, ich kann euch das wirklich nur empfehlen, geht
auf CelestiusRVR, ladet euch den Launcher runter und beziehungsweise folgt hier, wenn ihr spielen
wollt, guckt einfach hier nach, how to play, macht einfach die Anleitung durch und dann
könnt ihr spielen und ihr müsst keine, wie soll ich sagen, keine großartigen Bedenken
haben, dass man das nicht lernen kann oder so, es ist halt wie jedes ältere Spiel, es
ist relativ komplex bzw. halt einfach schon alt und die Leute haben es kapiert, wie es
funktioniert und was man für Spells benutzt, aber wenn ihr jetzt anfangt, ihr müsst ja
eh erstmal Level von 1 bis 50, da braucht ihr auch auf dem Server, würde ich mal sagen,
so 3-4 Tage für, wenn ihr relativ viel spielt, wenn ihr ganz neu seid und dann lernt ihr
euren Char auch, ihr fangt mit wenig Spells an und mit Level 50 habt ihr dann viele Spells,
also Daug hat eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Lernkurve, habt ihr das Relikt bekommen, noch
nicht, das Relikt ist wenn überhaupt hier in der Festung drin
und man sollte dran denken, seine Fähigkeiten ordentlich zu benutzen, weil eigentlich habe
ich noch sowas hier, da kann ich so eine Mini Wache beschwören, die einen Nahkampfschlag
auf mich abfängt, jetzt geht hier große Belagerung los, best game ever, so sieht es aus, also
die Hips werden sich das nicht einfach so gefallen lassen und nicht Defenden, das kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen, soll mal kurz updaten, den Watchtower haben wir noch nicht, die werden
auf jeden Fall hier irgendwann anrücken, einfach nur Liebe das Game, Pilz nicht da, doch ich
glaube schon, dass Pilz da ist, was ist da hinten, nix okay, Mr Slam ist da, kriegt Mr
Slam Damage, nee Mr Slam ist afk, Mr Slam kriegt Damage, Attacke Mr Slam, wir retten
dich, so da steht er, gib ihm Mr Slam, Gegner dead, und nichts wie weg, wenn jetzt die Gegner
kommen bin ich gefickt, und wenn das unser BG Lieder sieht, kriege ich mega Anschiss,
man kann übrigens die Keeps auch einschießen, also ihr seht ja das Keeper 100% Leben, man
kann mit den Katapulten auch Löcher in die Keeps schießen und sowas, guck hier ist die
Mauer schon ein bisschen kaputt, ich glaube das ist ein Bug, aber ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher ob das implementiert ist auf dem Server ehrlich gesagt, also auf dem Live Server kann
man Löcher ins Keep schießen, da kann man beispielsweise hier neben die Wand rausschießen
und sowas, also du kannst ja auch Türme einschießen und sowas mit den Belagerungswaffen, das dauert
aber eine Weile, Alter warum kriegen die alle so viel Damage, ist auf der anderen Seite
irgendwas, ach ne da oben sind Gegner, warum kriegen wir denn so viel Damage, hier ist
doch gar nichts, Alter was ist denn hier los, warum kriegen wir so viel Damage, es ist kein
einziger Gegner da, was macht uns so viel Damage, verstehe nicht, Belagerungswaffen
oder so der Gegner vielleicht, ja die Gegner haben viel Belagerungswaffen innen drinnen,
wir haben es, den Turm zumindest, wo sind denn die Malacca Hips, das ich habe gelernt
das ist so ein Universalwort, das kann man für alles verwenden, spielt man dieses Game,
kommt drauf an, das ist dir komplett dir überlassen wie du das Spiel spielst, es gibt Leute die
spielen das Spiel mega mega ernst Hardcore, da gehöre ich nicht mehr dazu, also ich meine
spätestens seit ich quasi nicht mehr live spiele ist das bei mir vorbei und dadurch
dass ich zum größten Teil BG spiele, Moment Moment Moment, ja ich habe Buffs endlich,
dadurch dass ich zum größten Teil BG spiele, muss ich jetzt auch nicht irgendwie 120% geben
jeden Fight, ich spiele das eigentlich sehr entspannt, ich war früher selbst der übelste
BG-Spieler der Welt, aber ich habe da echt zu 180 Grad Wände gemacht, ich bin immer noch
daran interessiert, dass es halbwegs optimiert gespielt wird, deswegen spiele ich auch hier
in mehr oder weniger fester Gruppe jeden Abend, mit gutem Setup für BG, mit viel Wizard-Damage,
bei Highland und Speed und allem, aber 8 vs. 8, den Stress kann ich mir nicht mehr geben.
Oh 75, 75 Gegner gesichtet, nice, ich meine wir sind doppelt so viel, aber immerhin, das
spielst du täglich, naja den Server gibt es erst seit 3 Wochen, früher habe ich das täglich
gespielt, es gibt kein anderes Spiel, wo ich so viel Zeit reingesteckt habe, es ist mega
spannend wenn gute Gruppen aufeinander treffen, ja das stimmt, also ich meine früher auf
live, also ich habe alle Reiche auf live gespielt, ich habe sogar auf dem US-Server gespielt
wieder in 2010, also ich habe von Alp habe ich durch, HIP habe ich durch, Midgard habe
ich die höchsten Shards gehabt auf live, da hatte ich einmal einen RR11 Skalde und dann
auf dem US-Server nochmal einen RR7 Skalde oder so, ist eigentlich so mit meinem Lieblings-Shar,
und wir haben da 8 vs. 8 alles leer gefickt, also es ist nicht so als hätte ich das damals
nicht ultra hardcore gespielt dieses Spiel, aber das könnte ich heute gar nicht mehr.
Das war so schlimm, dass auf Salis gar keiner mehr gegen uns spielen wollte auf live, die
Salis ist schon teilweise weg gerannt, aber ich könnte das heute nicht mehr, das wäre
mir viel zu stressig, weil wenn du 8er Gruppe vs. 8er Gruppe spielst, da kommt es halt auch
drauf an auf jeden einzelnen und du kannst da wirklich nicht Brain AFK davor setzen, du
musst deine Fähigkeiten gut benutzen und du musst vor allem ein ziemlich tiefes Verständnis
haben, was die gegnerischen Klassen machen, welche Spells die benutzen und du brauchst
genau das richtige Timing, oh guck mal 2 Gegner, ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha, Null, genial,
was ihr gerade gesehen habt, ha ha ha ha, Pong, was ihr gerade gesehen habt ist 80 Leute
sterben, nice, 80 Leute sind gestorben gegen 2 Gegner, das kann euch in Dark passieren,
ich weiß nicht ob man das überhaupt erkannt hat gerade, das waren 3-4 Gegner, also die
restliche Gruppe war irgendwie sonst wie, sonst wo, es waren 3 Gegner und die haben einfach
instant AE Damage gecast und alles weg, yes Delay for PvE Keeps is very important, krass,
heftig, aber guck mal wie viele das sind, das ist wirklich krass, also sollte das zu Problemen
werden, mache ich das nächste Mal wirklich ein Delay, aber hoffentlich gibt es jetzt
noch mehr, ich werde ausgecallt im Chat, dass ich streame, jetzt gehts los, oh jetzt wird
geflamed, jetzt wird geflamed, Leute müsst ihr halt die Augen aufmachen, wenn euch 4
Hips wegbomben, ich bin auch nicht gestorben, 50k RPs, krass, ja übrigens das ist das Problem,
wenn man einfach nur AFK Stick mitläuft, dann wirst du halt auch mal weggebombt, guck
mal wie sie abgehen, jetzt flippen sie aus, jetzt eskalieren sie alle hier, das ist das
was ich meine, in DAOG ist das so, da werden auch 35 plus jährige wieder zu 15 jährigen,
just don't stick and play brain AFK, dann passiert auch nichts, meine Güte, die regen
sich gerade richtig auf, dass ich ohne Delay beim PvE Keep streame, Wahnsinn, das ist gerade
richtig Drama, ich liebe MMO Drama, jetzt kriegt ihr das mal live, die sind gerade richtig
am eskalieren, MMO Drama at its best, so mal gucken ob wir das jetzt erwischen hier, ich
meine, sollte das wirklich zu Problem werden, muss ich mit Delay streamen, aber ich hasse
mit Delay zu streamen, ihr könnt die Messages nicht lesen, jetzt sind sie mal richtig abgefuckt,
jetzt sind sie richtig stick, die müssen einfach nicht stick AFK rumlaufen, easy, dann
hast du keine Probleme, wie gesagt, normalerweise mach ich noch was ganz anderes, ich hab mir
bloß gedacht, dass wir zur Abwechslung ja mal DAOG streamen könnten, wichtig, wir müssen
Speedwarp setzen am Seitentor, ohne Speedwarp ist ziemlich blöd, hier müssen Speedwarps
hin, da stehen schon Speedwarps, alles voller Speedwarps, guck mal da sind Gegner, aber
ich chase nicht, weil sonst krieg ich von Polemo Ärger, ihr müsst den Chat sehen,
es ist riesen Drama gerade, weil wir weggebombt wurden, weil die Leute Brain AFK gestickt
haben, Guard Acro on Healers, ah dann, CCen wir die Wachen nochmal, wenn wir jetzt natürlich
den CC nicht brechen würden, wär natürlich noch nicer, Viva Bavaria, Mordzwaltet war
eures Amtes, ist ja Wahnsinn, jetzt eskalieren sie hier, Wache weg, richtig Drama Boys am
Start, Mordcheck, wo sind die ganzen Mods am Start, Sekunde, ich muss mich mal kurz
dem Chat widmen, das artet mir jetzt ein bisschen aus, so, der Patri ist schon da, nice, so
weiter gehts, oh nein, Dark Age of Camelot, ja, best game ever, ok das kriegen wir nicht,
da kannst du nichts machen, da sind zu viele Defender drin, keine Chance, gucken dass die
uns nicht ass jammen von der Seite, jetzt tauchen wir nirgends mal ein paar Gegner auf,
nee, den kriegen wir nicht down, nein die Server sind nicht abgeschaltet, das ist PvP,
was ihr hier seht sind alles echte Spieler, kann man oft genug sagen, alles echte Spieler
und das da oben alles echte Gegner, die Server wurden nicht abgeschaltet, die Live Server
gibt es noch, aber da spielt kaum einer, das hier ist ein Free Shot, das hier ist für
jeden den es interessiert, das ist Celestios RVR, ups, falsch, also wer es mal ausprobieren
will, ihr müsst einfach bei Celestios RVR auf die Webseite gehen, gucken how to play,
im Prinzip müsst ihr nur das Spiel inszeniert euch einen Account anlegen und fertig, so was
macht das Tor, ich guck mal kurz wie weit das Tor ist, Tor ist 46%, welcher Fraktion
spielt so, ich spiel Albion, das sind quasi gerade so 160 Alps, das ist ein Fanprojekt,
richtig, das ist ein Fanprojekt, aber ich muss jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen, ich kann
grad nicht so wirklich viel machen, ich hab selbst nur 14 FPS oder so, ich kann nicht
wirklich gut Gegner anklicken und auch nicht wirklich gut auf Gegner casten, so unser Minion
ist down, game lass mich die, alter lass mich die Gegner anklicken, not in view, nice game,
super, not in view, da oben ist Giga Chat, Leute endlich, auf den hab ich schon den ganzen
Tag gewartet, Giga Chat ist am Start, alter wir kriegen richtig Damage, grade reingefahren,
vielleicht sollen wir mal ein bisschen zurück alle, bis wir wieder aufgeheilt sind, also
ich bleib jetzt hier erstmal stehen, was soll ich großartig sparen, ja, so, ich spam jetzt
einfach ein bisschen auf die Gegner AE, dass sie nicht so viel zaubern können, mehr kann
ich nicht machen, also in solchen Keepfights kommt es hauptsächlich darauf an, dass du
Leute hast, die ein bisschen was aushalten und gut rammen können, die Mits sind jetzt
ready, ah ok, so gleich leben wieder alle, sollen wir aufpassen, dass die hier nicht
so viel rumcasten können die Jungs, wo liegt da ein Zauberin rum, ach ist immer noch dead,
ne Zauberin liegt da hinten, Zauberin liegt da hinten irgendwo rum, hier sind ganz schön
viele tot, wie siehts hier an der Seite aus, alter wie viele, wie viele Wächterdinger da
rumstehen, aber das soll dann eine aufpolierte Version sein, das ist das originale Game,
am kleinen können die nichts machen, ach ich mein Camelot Unchained, nee Camelot Unchained
soll ein komplett neues Game werden, aber das ist neun Jahre in Entwicklung und die
haben nichts auf die Reihe bekommen bisher, die zeigen immer noch Konzeptzeichnung, das
muss man sich einmal vorstellen, neun Jahre in Entwicklung und Konzeptzeichnung, da
wird Camelot Unchained nie rauskommen, so was macht das Tor, muss mal kurz nach unserem
Tor gucken, 29% gleicht das Tor auf Leute, gachi bass, hätte ich ein bisschen mehr FPS
könnte ich vielleicht auch Gegner interupten, bisschen mehr Damage, auf zeig dich mal, also
normalerweise ist es mit meinem Job die Gegner zu interupten, dass sie nicht zaubern können,
ich krieg den nicht angeklickt und da vorne rein will ich nicht, wo sind die Gegner, und
wir müssen auf jeden Fall auch am Seitentor gucken, dass nix reingeht, guck mal hier geht
auch schon was ab, wird alles schon abgefarmt, ok nice, so jetzt müsste gleich das Tor auf
sein, 15%, so schöner E auf die Wache spammen, dass die Gegner nicht zaubern können da drinnen,
haben es die Leute eigentlich wieder beruhigt, hier geblieben, stehen geblieben, Celestius,
genau das Celestius ist der einzige Freeshot, den es aktuell gibt, es gibt noch Atlas aber
Atlas ist Beta, so Tor offen 8% noch, so ich muss die Caster unbedingt interupten, sonst
RIP unsere Leute an den Ramm, ach Mist ich hab meinen Quickcast nicht gebindet, ich wundere
mich als warum meine Shortcuts nicht funktionieren, ich hab die hier gar nicht eingerichtet auf
dem Account, ich hab normalerweise auf der Windows Taste Quickcast und was hab ich denn
sonst noch, genau ich hab meine RA auf Shift, äh nicht auf Shift auf Caps Lock, ich wundere
mich die ganze Zeit warum geht das nicht, muss ich gleich unbedingt machen, muss ich
mir aufschreiben, Keybindings, ja Patrick gerade deswegen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass bei Camelot Unchained jemals was rauskommt, 9 Jahre ist das Geld weg aber noch nix nennenswert
ist rausgekommen, es ist Crash, guck mal bei mir aus der Gruppe, Crash gerade laufendes
Game bei den Leuten, zu viele Alps am Start, von wo casten sie, hier ist ne Wache, so Tor
ist auf, Tor ist auf, wir können nicht rein, also ohne Mist selbst mit, nimm den Back,
selbst mit 200 Alps können wir hier nicht unstinkt anstinken, ok Knas, ich muss mal,
ich muss mal, Pilze, hör mal plus auf Pilze, au au Leute ihr müsst zurück, ihr könnt
hier nicht fighten, es sind viel zu viele Gegner für so wenig Alps, guckt euch das
mal an, die pushen hier mal richtig ran, ihr müsst da rein pushen Leute keine Chance,
wenn ihr da nicht rein pusht, ähm, haste gelitten, ich setz hier mal nen Speedwarp bisschen
vorne hin, jawoll jetzt gehen sie down, oh die Tangler müssen weg, die Tangler müssen
weg, sonst routen die mich und ich kann mich nicht bewegen, jawoll macht sie platt, noch
mehr Gegners, oh wir müssen zurück, wir müssen zurück, zurück, zurück, immer schön den
Speedwarp rein, ok jetzt gibt es ein bisschen Fights, hallo Maus please anklicken, wir müssen
auf jeden Fall ein Stückchen zurück, ok zurück, zurück, zurück, zurück, keine Chance, werden
zu viele, die müssen weg, ähm, mit wieder nur US Primetime, ja das hab ich auch schon
gelesen, dass ähm, die mit nur in NA-Time was auf die Reihe kriegen, also in Dark muss
man auch wissen wann man weg muss und das ist eindeutig, die drücken uns, guck mal
eben, wir sehen es doch, die drücken uns weg an der Seite hier, wenn die Alps mit
pushen geht das, aber so wird das nix, ah vielleicht kriege ich, wo ist denn mein Clary,
da, da, wo sind meine Clary, ach da, cool, einmal nearside heal please, einmal nearside
heal please, also das sorgt dafür, dass ich keine Range mehr auf meinen Casts habe und
ich im Prinzip nichts machen kann, ich mein ihr müsst mal gucken, Serverinfo, wir reden
hier von einem Spiel von 2001 und einem Fanprojekt, 2100 Spieler und ähm, irgendwie 1000 Leute
im Grenzgebiet, das riecht heftig, Tower open, ok, geb ihm, Power clearen, wir machen jetzt
erstmal den Tower, Alter wie es ruckelt, ich find's heftig, dass ein Game ruckelt aus 2001
auf einem halbwegs aktuellen Gaming Rechner, what the fuck, Storms nice, Eats, so sieht
das übrigens aus, wenn man stirbt, aber übersrennen sie ja trotzdem easy, ja passiert nix, also
pushen können die uns nicht, wir sind viel zu viele gerade, hat das früher auch so geruckelt,
früher hat das noch mehr geruckelt, das hier ruckelt jetzt ja gar nicht so krass, das sind
ja immerhin 20 FPS, früher hast du das Spiel mit 3 FPS gespielt, früher hattest du 3 FPS
und die Leute haben alle gesagt, cloak off, cloak off, weil das ist weniger Animationen
braucht, das wäre natürlich nice, wenn mich jetzt noch jemand wiederbeleben könnte, der
da, jawoll, guter Mann, guter Mann, hips just everywhere, ok ich guck mal kurz vom Dach,
kann man nen Buff reinhauen, ok ich glaub ich krieg das Beste grad gar nicht mit da
unten, na das können wir nicht machen, hier unten ist, hier unten ist, wieso sieht das
doch ganz wie ne Alpstar, alles gut, doch gar nix, egal ich push da jetzt runter, erstmal
schön Damage nehmen, aber meine Heiler sind auf Zack, die haben es drauf, also das muss
man echt sagen, es ist mega nice in der Gruppe zu spielen mit gescheiten Heilern, oh das
sind viele, das sind viele, muss ich weg, unbedingt weg, unbedingt weg, ok das sind
zu viele, das sind zu viele, mal gucken ob wir noch ein paar gekillt kriegen, oh oh Zauberin
muss da vorne weg, vielleicht krieg ich noch ein bisschen CC rein, aber viel mehr kann
ich da nicht machen, so erstmal die Gegner hinstellen, guck deswegen mein ich Hexe ist
wichtig jetzt können die sich nicht mehr bewegen, jetzt pushen sie aber ordentlich
ran hier, lasst mich in Ruhe, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt umdrehen nochmal drüber rutschen,
die trauen sich ganz schön weit vor, die trauen sich ganz schön weit vor, wenn wir da jetzt
einmal drauf gehen sind die weg, wir sind viel viel mehr,
erstmal kurz alles weg weg weg weg, das Problem ist sobald ich ordentlich Damage rein kriege
kann ich nicht mal casten, wir müssen echt ein bisschen aufpassen, dass wir nicht überfahren
werden von der Seite, wir sind mehr, also wir könnten da theoretisch drauf pushen,
aber warten wir mal ab was unser Anführer sagt, ein Pilz, Leute ich sag euch ihr werdet
Pilze hassen, wenn ihr Dark anfangt oder solltet ihr Dark anfangen, ihr werdet Pilze gerade
Tangler, ihr werdet Tangler hassen, das sind Pilze die routen euch für eine Minute
tun, ihr könnt nicht mal vorwärts laufen, das schlimmste was sich die Leute, die Designer
von diesem Spiel jemals ausgedacht haben, Tangler, Tangler ist echt, ich weiß nicht
wer auf die Idee gekommen ist, hat sich gedacht lasst mal Tangler in das Spiel einbauen, das
ist eine super Idee, wir müssen die Hips polemonen, sieht man die wenigsten halbwegs
gut kann man die Pilze zerstören, ja klar ich hab die Pilze ja auch gerade kaputt gemacht
hier, da guck mal da sind sie, diese grauen Dinger da sind die Pilze, ja Tangler, Tangler
genau, wenn du dich mit Celestius verbinden willst, du musst das Spiel runterladen und
dann den Celestius, oh wir pushen, wir pushen Leute, ich hab's verpasst, wir pushen, gibs
ihn, wir pushen, drauf auf sie und schon sind die Hips weg, jawoll erstmal alles schön
gemetzt, so muss das sein, so und jetzt kriegen sie auch einen Rute hinterher, Mist ich hab
meinen Quickcast nicht geq bindet, das ist wirklich dumm auf dem, ich muss gleich Quickbindings
machen, sonst kann ich nicht spielen gescheit, wenn ich jedes mal klicken muss, ihh nur
Noobs klicken, fall back jawoll, ok aber jetzt seht ihr mal so sieht das aus wenn Gegner
am Start sind, also wenn Keep Defended ist, du hast wirklich Schwierigkeiten rein zu kommen,
genau so siehts aus, der chat erklärt das alles ziemlich gut, das hier sind Buffs die
ich habe, das sind Buffs die ich aktuell habe und das sind alles meine Spells, so siehts
aus, so und ich muss gleich wenn der Fight vorbei ist, ich muss unbedingt meine Qbinds
machen, was hab ich denn normalerweise, Qbinded, ich hab Dings Qbinded, ne was, hmmm, was hab
ich denn, wie hab ich denn Sachen geq binded normalerweise, ich bin gerade ein bisschen
verwirrt, weil da hab ich an den Settings schon 3 Wochen nichts mehr rumgestellt, Quickcast
auf Windows-Taste, E-Core auf Caps hab ich normalerweise, genau das muss ich gleich machen,
unbedingt, ich map mal kurz mein Quickbind, remap a key, Windows-Taste auf 6, ok continue,
nice, hä, warum geht das nicht, Windows-Left auf 6, hallo, game please, ok ich kann meine
Tasten nicht quickbinden, alles klar, warum kann ich meine Tasten nicht quickbinden,
ich weiß es nicht, kann das sein, dass wir abhauen, ne oder, ich blick nicht mehr durch,
Leute, das ist mir zu viel auf einmal, also 30 Zauber, die aktiviert werden können oder
sind da auch viele Passive dabei, das sind nicht Sachen, die ich mir Geld selbst gebe,
das sind hauptsächlich Sachen, die ich von unseren Heilern kriege in der Gruppe, ha,
die ganzen Buffs hier oben, Ostar Tarmac da, die ganzen Sachen von hier oben sind von den
Heilern, das sind Schilder, die ich mir selbst gebe, oh fuck, all das sind das viele Gegner,
jawoll, deswegen braucht man eine Hexe in dem Spiel, einfach, einfach alle gestunt,
damn, guckt euch an, nichts kann casten von den Gegnern, oh, oh, oh, nein, nein, nein,
nein, lass, lass den mich in Ruhe, nope, nope, nope, nope, so nicht, äh, wo sind denn alle
hin, sind die alle im Turm, ich hab's jetzt verpasst, Leute, ich hab's verpasst, wo sind
denn die Alps alle hin, sind die im Turm, so, demetzen mal schnell, oh, oh, Gegners, jetzt,
jetzt wird's mir aber ein bisschen brenzlig hier, sind die im Turm, wo sind meine Leute,
jetzt hab ich, ich hab zu viel mit euch geschwätzt, ich hab's nicht mitgekriegt, oh ne, wir sind
im Turm, fuck, okay, jetzt hab ich ein Problem, ich komm nicht mehr in den Turm rein, vielleicht,
vielleicht könnt ihr mich hochressen, okay, Yolo, Yolo in den Turm, oh ne, ne, ne, okay,
Schild an, Schild an, nein, das war Mock an, fuck, jetzt hab ich mich auch noch im Eifer
des Geschäfts, im Eifer des Gefechts verdrückt, geil, ich hätte mal ein Schild gebraucht,
jetzt kann ich, jetzt bin ich dead, okay, nice, GG Eats, so, ihr macht jetzt erst mal nix,
hübs, muss mal ein Stückchen weg, so, der kriegt Damage, bleibst du hier stehen, erst
mal geroutet, da kommen die nächsten, alter, kipp um, kipp um, jawoll, next, jawoll, sterben,
sterben, hübs, sterben, die Alps sind alle in dem Turm drin, das Problem ist, ich hab's
verpennt reinzugehen, alles stehen bleiben, please, nein, Nier-Side, Nier-Side ist schlecht,
Nier-Side weg, Nier-Side, alles klar, ich muss mich gerade konzentrieren, dass ich nicht
sterbe, weil ich voll vergessen habe, jawoll, der braucht Damage, gib ihm, 98, 79, ne, nix,
okay, komm ich jetzt in den Turm rein, schläft alles, und Line of Sight ausnutzen müssen
wir, also, oh fuck, alter, wie viele das sind, shit, oh nein, guck mal, wie viele das sind,
ich bin auch Hutimmun zum Glück, sehr viel, oh nein, jetzt werden wir weggepusht, fuck,
okay Leute, ich verpiss mich, sofern ich noch wegkomme, ich verpiss mich, okay, ich bin
dead, ich bin dead, vorbei, RIP, F, da machst du nix, ich hab's verpennt in den Turm reinzugehen,
F, ich hab's verpennt in den Turm reinzugehen, ich hab mit euch gelabert und hab's nicht
mitbekommen, jetzt müssen wir warten, Leute, jetzt müssen wir warten, gucken, wie das
Ganze ausgeht, weil die Alps sind ja in dem Turm drinnen, und wir sind immer noch so viele,
die können diesen Turm nicht stürmen, das klappt nicht, aber jetzt sind's richtig viele
Gegner, guckt euch das mal an, Gegner, Gegner, ich hab jetzt einen doofen Spot, viel mehr
sieht man da jetzt nicht, ähm, also richtig viele Gegner, aber solange die Leute bei mir
noch im Turm drin sind, warte ich mal, vielleicht machen sie die ja noch platt.
Wo sind eigentlich die Mits? Wird mal Zeit, wird mal Zeit für drei, drei Wege Gangbang
hier, da ist mal richtig Hyper Action, durch das mal an, man sieht's jetzt, man sieht's
jetzt nicht richtig, ich hab glaub ich die, wartet mal, haha, man sieht doch ein bisschen
was, man sieht ungefähr 100 Gegner oder so vor dem Turm, na top, ich werd jetzt nicht
releasen, auch weil irgendjemand, äh, wie lange liegst du da jetzt rum, äh, bis ich
wiederbelebt werde oder bis der Timer voll ist, das Problem ist jetzt, wir sind quasi
komplett, also hier ist der Eingang zum Grenzland von den Hips, und wir sind hier, ich komm
hier im Leben nicht solo mehr hin, keine Chance, ich weiß nicht warum man mad ist, weil das
ist doch best game ever, alter das sind aber richtig viele jetzt, der Jura, danke für
den Sub, die Katze ist im Weg, stimmt, die Katze ist im Weg, hab ich ja gar nicht dran
gedacht, ne, also hier ist der Eingang normalerweise ins Grenzgebiet und wir sind hier unten, was
im Endeffekt heißt, ich krieg übrigens immer noch AP's zwischendurch, was im Endeffekt
heißt, ähm, hier komm ich nie im Leben solo hin, also was ich machen könnte ist, ok meine
Gruppe ist zuversichtlich, dass wir gewinnen, alles klar, ähm, was wir machen, also was
man machen kann ist, man kann mit dem Schiff, man kann mit dem Schiff von hier, ist das
ungefähr, ist hier nicht richtig drauf, aber ok, von hier kann man, ähm, fahren mit dem
Schiff von hier an der Insel vorbei übers Meer, hier oben rein und dann kann man entweder
dahin fahren oder dahin, und meistens, also wenn man hier runter fährt, kommt man relativ
weit hin, aber ich komm im Leben nicht solo hier hin, oh, oh, wir pushen Leute, wir pushen,
wir pushen, ich krieg leider nix mit, ich link am Arsch der Welt, aber wir pushen, alter,
es gibt AP's, die werden gerade gefickt, die hips, gachi bass, richtig gachi bass, guckt
euch das mal an, alp kill spam, gib ihm, ist das rein pvp, äh nein, ist nicht rein pvp,
aber es sind immer noch sau viele hips, da vorne rennt glaub ich Pilz rum, ich seh nix,
ich link am Arsch der Welt, der beste Fight des Abends und ich seh nix, big action, they
can't rest me, and we can't see anything, much hips, also, es gibt PvE, du spielst bis
level 50, pve, und glänzt deinen shark hin, ok, gleich werd ich gerest angeblich, mal
gucken, nee, das können sie nicht machen, ich schwachsinn, ich kann nicht gerest werden
aktuell, geht höchstens wenn, da hinten sind so viele hips, ich bin halt blöd, ich
bin weggelaufen, ich hätte eigentlich am Turm sterben sollen, wenn ich am Turm gestorben
wäre, hätten wir mich hochresten können, aber so lege ich am Arsch der Welt rum, mal
abwarten, ja ich bin halt doof gestorben, aber so ist es halt, so ist es halt, guck
mal, da kommt einer, da isser, stream sniper, ich sehs ihm an, guck mal, der hat wenig Leben,
deswegen läuft das so langsam, top, alter wie viele das sind und ich seh nix, ich werd
aber auf jeden Fall nicht releasen, wie gesagt, ich komme solo hier nicht mehr hin, keine
Chance, aber es gab ganz gut RPs jetzt, ich mein wir haben immerhin 16k die Stunde, insgesamt
haben wir 40k gemacht, oh es gibt RPs Leute, es gibt RPs, nice, RPs, oh jetzt, gibs ihn,
oh, oh, oh, das sieht schlecht aus, ich seh bloß die Lebensanzeige meiner Gruppe, ist
es ein Problem, ich hab kein Discord an, ich hab den Chat geblürt, dass man nix sieht,
es ist kacke das Spiel zu erklären mit Delay im Chat, ich kann mit Delay streamen, also
wenn das wirklich Probleme macht, kann ich mit Delay streamen, das Problem ist nur, da
kann ichs auch gleich sein lassen, im Prinzip kannst du so mit oder ohne, also wenn du wirklich
interagieren willst mit dem Chat und willst was über das Spiel erzählen, kannst eigentlich
mit delay stream verstehen die leute halt nicht aber was willst du machen es gibt im
prinzip nur die möglichkeit mit also ohne delay oder gar nicht
au au au leute ihr kriegt aber fett damage
sehr spannend leute oder wir liegen hier und gucken zu aber wir kriegen ps bei der
gelegenheit wo wir gerade dabei sind während ich hier so rumliege sollten
froh sein dass viele leute reinkommen ich glaube die server betreiber sollten
die den stream sehen sind wahrscheinlich wirklich ganz froh drüber wir kriegen
so fett ps vielleicht vielleicht au au au leute nicht sterben nicht sterben
nicht sterben nicht sterben or kops dauen top die killen uns jetzt
aber wir können auch ganz das ist ausgeglichen und ich bin ich dabei ich
sehe es nicht ich lege am arsch der welt rum mann aber ps gehen gut ab
ich meine kläris haben den instant dress das würde theoretisch funktionieren
aber kannst du ein kann sich mal durstier du gehst als kläri drauf wenn du mich
viel die kippen gut um aber wie kriegen auch auf den sack ich glaube das ist
gerade ein mega geiler ausgeglichener fight und ich kriege nichts davon mit
weil ich hinterm tollen weil ich hinter diesem kackturm liege
war da booms dings 19 monat für den sub
jetzt und wisst ihr was das beste an diesem spiel ist man hat jetzt gar nicht
gesehen wir feiten gerade die mit sind da die mit sind da wir feiten ja gerade nur
all bjorn gegen hibernia wenn jetzt die dritte fraktion kommt das ist das was
alle mmos wir gewinnen leute wir gewinnen es sieht so aus als können wir man sieht
nichts rettungsaktion poggers hier am laufen was kein anderes mmo so gut
hingekriegt hat selbst wenn du ein riesen zerkast aus alps und ein paar hips
selbst wenn nur die hälfte an mitz kommt und im richtigen moment in den fight
reingeht können die gewinnen am ende und das hat kein mmo jemals auch nur
ansatzweise wieder so gut hingekriegt wie da gehts auf kamelot du brauchst diese
drei fraktionen wenn du nur zwei fraktionen hast das funktioniert nicht
guckt euch world of warcraft server an du hast world of warcraft server die haben
90 prozent allianz 90 prozent horde klar es gibt ein paar ausgeglichene aber
durch dieses system mit drei verschiedenen realms
they are getting fucked sagt mein chat das schön leute fack die hips ich sag
immer realtime also ich kann gar nicht schreiben
kann ich nicht schreiben winch realtime 70 prozent
und ich sehe es halt nicht ja sorry leute bin halt doof gestorben was ist
ein tier nicht sterben mit bg die mit bg kommt und ich sehe nichts ist das bitter
ach nee es gab wir sind an allen die kommt gar nicht eher aber guck mal da
wäre es die stream sniper sind am start ich glaube nicht dass die stream sniper
sind mein gott ich bin ja auch dumm gestorben
alter tio nein ich bin ich tio ach so eher nein nein das ist nicht tio das ist
nicht tio das ist nicht tio
oder sind hips das ist der alps das ist der alps vielleicht kriegst du den rest
gib mir das blies blies blies blies mich als als als blies ihr habt die klärin
dabei retz mich hilfe letztlich guck zu euch an laufen einfach vorbei das sind
wir welche hier
ich glaube ich glaube das war es jetzt wir sind noch fast alle tot
wir sind wir sind dauernd vergessen glaube wir sind alle dauernd ja ja ja wir
haben ordentlich was gekillt also wir also ich nicht
ach leute warum was ist denn mit euch los was ist denn mit euch nur falsch
könnt ihr mir das erklären was habt ihr für probleme heute dass das spiel keiner
spielt gut
fack wir sind wir sind gefuckt wir sind wir sind dauernd
heute kein hr q chat nee nee
mercy rest das wäre es jetzt ja
ich glaube dass ich glaube das verloren jetzt ja das das problem das ist in dauer
kalt echt so es ist gerade soll ich sagen gerade wenn man neu anfängt
benno post dann ok release nice gerade wenn man neu anfängt darf man sich
nicht abschrecken lassen dass es halt so ein paar ganz spezielle fälle gibt in
dem spiel zum beispiel es gibt zeige euch das mal ja please
lass mich mal baffen irgendwo hier ist der buff port da es gibt zum beispiel ein
advice chat kann ich euch nicht zeigen weil ich habe sehr geblört es gibt
ein advice chat und da kann man da ist eigentlich dafür gedacht dass man so
sachen fragen kann wie was ist die beste kleriskillung oder sowas aber es gibt so
super tolle elite leute die der meinung sind dass man in dem advice chat an den
leuten was rät was verskillt ist und die finden sich danach furchtbar geil bei ich
verstehe es nicht wie man in einem spiel was 20 jahre alt ist so ultra krass am
abhaken sein kann dass man auch nicht mal will dass neue leute das spiel
anfangen verstehe ich verstehe das nicht ist mir unbegreiflich ja das ist quasi
das microcontroller forum in da ja genau das
ich ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen
jetzt mal ernsthaft immerhin es kann sein dass die mit und vorhin gebombt haben
weil ich ohne delay gestreamt habe das kann schon sein aber erstens man kann
einfach ans dicklauf und nicht wie der letzte brain dead alp da hinterher rennen
und sich wegbomben lassen ich bin auch nicht gestorben oder aber man muss halt
einfach sehen dass streams spieler zum spiel bringen
die frage was mehr wiegt mal ein weib dafür vielleicht ein langlebigerer
server
ich meine das spiel hat normalerweise fünf fünf zuschauer oder so also ich
verstehe ich verstehe kann ich nicht nachvollziehen
bennett gehen wir habe ich gehört teleport
und an der stelle angewähnt wir können echt froh sein dass wir so ein high iq
5 hat bg lieder haben der hat gute taktiken drauf klar der scheiß die
leute immer zwischendurch an der hat gute taktiken drauf aber es ist
unglaublich wichtig gerade wenn man bg spielen will dass die leute alle an einem
strang ziehen und das funktioniert einfach bei prolemo am besten
deswegen bin ich froh dass wir einen ordentlichen bg lieder hier haben
da darf er auch ruhig mal ein bisschen ausflippen
so mal gucken was wir jetzt machen ich habe die hälfte vom fight verpasst
die flur haben an eigentlich 20 oder 37
hoxie sehe ich auch so dann hören die leute nehmen es den ist da nice japp
achten platz auffüllen
kommst zu bennett
gut während wir jetzt hier stehen und baffen gibt was gibt es noch was ich
über das spiel erzählen könnte ich habe jetzt leider nicht so viel chat
geguckt in letzter zeit jura hat subscribd dankeschön für den zapp habe
ich nicht gesehen richtig brain afk gewesen ich muss mal kurz
in das creator dashboard reingucken
sticken jura hat subscribd unleashed mv hat subscribd
cyrus hat mich gehostet vor 34 und cyrus habe ich gar nicht gesehen
dankeschön für den host ich bin richtig brain afk gewesen gerade
reiz hat subscribd auch nicht gesehen leute dankeschön für die subs gibt es
in dem game skins und kisten ja und nein es gibt skins es gibt effekte und die
kannst du dir in der hauptstadt drauf machen also zum beispiel diese rüstung
die ich hier an hab das ist ein skin aber die kosten nichts also die skins
bezahlst du auf diesem surfer entweder mit kopfgeldpunkten die kriegst du wenn
du gegner killst oder mit platz tokens platz tokens kriegst du auch im rvr kannst
dir aussuchen so die haben die haben in der hauptstadt haben ein reskin ein
reskin npc da kann man sich seine rüstung reskin seine waffe reskin und
die haben den effekt effekt merchant da kann man sich da beispielsweise klitzer
effekt auf seinen stab drauf machen und so was wenn man da drauf steht
das ist auch noch was was ich vielleicht mal erklären sollte für leute die sich
jetzt überlegen ob sie anfangen soll sollen auf selestius oder nicht
normalerweise auf live ist es so man erstellt sich nicht fängt bei level 1
an level dann durch bis 50 so das ist hier in prinzip auch so aber mit dem
unterschied sie haben hier extra quests und killtas die das level schneller
machen also kannst alle paar level kannst du den neues gebiet und du hast
auch du hast auch quests die basic rps bringen und sowas also die haben sich
wirklich mühe gegeben die hallo ich möchte irgendwo in so
ein boot rein please boot game boote backen manchmal rum und wenn man dann
fertig gelewelt ist wenn man dann auf nach eine gilde für deine community als
starthilfe ich habe eine gilt ich mache keine extra gilde mehr es gibt ja
außerdem der start gilde wenn man dann zumindest worauf ich raus will ist wenn
man dann fertig ist auf fast 6l9 ich schaffe vielleicht morgen dann
r7 wenn man dann 50 ist dann ist es anders als auf dem live server auf dem
live server musst du erst mal entweder man im china shop was kaufen was ich
euch natürlich nicht empfehlen würde oder du musst erst mal klasse farmen
sonstige sachen machen und hier musst du im prinzip nur rvr machen und wenn du
rvr machst kriegst du solche tokens und von diesen die kriegst du auch noch auf
andere art art und weise aber rvr finde ich ist das angenehmste wenn du pvp
machst dann kriegst du diese tokens und von diesen tokens kaufst du die
ausrüstung da kaufst du zum beispiel hier artefakte du kaufst dir spezielle
stäbe und und umhänge und so was die die skills drauf haben und dann bist du
irgendwann voll ausgerüstet also im prinzip kannst du mit 50 ins rvr gehen
ist das ist das bootbug oder ob das war bootbug was ich eben hatte oder kannst
mit 50 ins rvr gehen und du machst blatt tokens und rüstest dich aus das finde
ich deutlich besser als wie das ganze im auf live ist
so sieht es aus also ich kann zu jedem empfehlen wer bock drauf hat geht hier
selestius rvr how to play liest sich das durch im prinzip ist ganz einfach
geladen das game runter patch das game ladet euch den starter runter und
meldet euch mit eurem discord account an ok nicht so sehr sticken leute ihr
wisst bomber groups und so übrigens eine sache die ich euch noch gar nicht
gezeigt habe weil ich viel zu sehr durch den stream abgelenkt war nicht nur hat
die klasse die ich spiele quasi die besten cc spells im spiel und ordentlich
damage nein ich habe auch noch ein pet guck mal ich habe ein pet also hexe ist
wirklich eines der besten klasse im ganzen spiel kann man nichts sagen aber
trotzdem nicht so mega op weil die anderen reiche auch ähnlich
overpowerede sachen aber hexe ist schon krass richtig guter damage richtig gutes
cc noch ein pet dabei also wenn einer einen caster also wenn einer hier nen
nennt man das in anderen spielen dann ein caster spielen will solo ist hexe das
beste aber ich würde im spiel generell nicht empfehlen casters solo zu spielen
hast du in dem spiel nicht auch dein festival date kennengelernt doch habe
ich gut aufgepasst in videos ja habe ich auch mein festival date kennengelernt
richtig der chat weiß bescheid ich habe so viel lebenszeit in diesem spiel
verschwendet das könnte was heißt verschwendet verbracht verschwendet ist es
ja nicht weil es macht mega bock als in jedem anderen spiel wie gesagt ich habe
bestimmt ich habe bestimmt zwei jahre meines lebens in game hier verbracht also
2 insgesamt 2 echte jahre was denn da vorne gegner das drei tage festival genau
so sieht es aus chat ich habe so ich habe so wohl meine erste freundin
kennengelernt in diesem spiel in diesem spiel mit also so richtige somit wann
habe ich 2001 2002 sprich 16 17 17 in dem dreh und auch das festival date und so
was ja ja zauberin wo ist denn zauberin schon wieder warum ist zauberin tot ich
habe wirklich viel zu viel zeit in diesem spiel verbracht
der alp zerk ist unterwegs wie viel sind wir denn eigentlich bg count
bg count und 200 als meine güte gut so viele sind nicht hier so viel sind in
der bg
auch hier geht was ink gib ihm doch nicht den da man den da btf meine tap
skills man auch schon mal besser jawoll alle gemäßt und drauf geben nein nein du
karstest nicht kollege du karstest nicht
ihr kriegt auf den sack ich brauche meine quick bindings ich kann die ganzen
spells gar nicht richtig auslösen so was machen wir denn eigentlich was ist der
plan hier was was ist der plan wollen wir das kieb oder was wollen wir machen
ok man darf nicht hinterher rennen wenn man hinterher rennt kriegt man vom bg
leader ein riesen anschiss wer sich jetzt fragt ob das echte gegner waren ja das
waren echte gegner das ist auch ein echter gegner der einfach mitten in uns
rein rennt weil er sonst nichts besseres zu tun hat
bastion alter bastion aus dem game kommt das übrigens bastion alter bastion was
ich früher mit famian immer gelabert habe die sinnlose scheiße in den videos das
ist hier alles entstanden
easy so was ist unser plan was machen wir
in ein mit speed war brennen machen wir top sehr gute idee
aber mal gegners wir dürfen nicht chasen wenn wenn wir chasen gibt es ärger
never chase peanuts
aha aha nope die sind gerade noch rechtzeitig abgehauen
vielleicht von der anderen seite bleibt ihr da bleibt ihr da den krieg ich mit
amnesie den krieg ich mit amnesie den krieg ich mit amnesie jawoll kein speed
für dich kein speed für dich aber die alps wollen nicht ok polemow hat die
alps schon gut im griff bei jeder ich sag euch wie es ist bei jedem anderen bg
leader werden die leute jetzt gechast 50
kilometer dieser einen gruppe hinterher aber polemow hat die leute im griff wenn
die leute jetzt so sehr aus der reihe tanzen dann gibt es gleich bann für die
bg für den abend dann ist vorbei manchmal übertreibt das ein bisschen
aber der hat sie gut im griff und es macht auch spaß ich pisse mich jeden
abend weg wenn ich bei denen im discord bin wie er wie er ausrastet aber macht es
schon gut
guck im chat kriegt man jetzt schon gesagt land man soll die man soll die
lampe ausmachen aber ich lasse die lampe an damit ihr was seht weil ansonsten
seht ihr ja nichts richtiges und jetzt ärgern wir unsere kleris wieder indem
wir einfach mal vom baum springen nicht vom baum vom turm springen
das ist fies ich hasse das wenn ich selbst klare spiele er regiert mit eiser
einer hand ja das könnte man so sagen
foxy ich weiß er hat ja auch versucht mit gar zu spielen aber das hat nicht so
hingehauen aber mit mit essen kommt ist was komplett anderes
alps haben schon immer gerne gezerkt auch auf live und mit ist eher so das
elitereich zumindest das selbst ernannte möchte gern elitereich zwar schon immer
so
wir sind wirklich viele
ich lasse mal die map aus man weiß ja nie auch guck mal da vorne sind mit die
vorn abhauen ich habe für nichts aufgehört zu spielen als new frontier
kam nicht wegen new frontier sondern irgendwie war für mich die luft draus
also ich habe mein skalte komplett solo gespielt bis glaube neuner drei oder so
irgendwie hatte ich keinen bock mehr so öl muss weg wenn man öl abkriegt ist man
quasi instant tot
ja 11 heiler nice wie hieß du vielleicht kennen wir uns
also ich hieß pox mit meinem skalte ich habe wie gesagt hauptsächlich solo
gespielt bei nf aufgehört die ritme sagt mir nix
ich war der einzige schwert skalte auf phoenix weil schwert eigentlich übel
sagt aber irgendwie spiel ich trotzdem am liebsten
schwert ist das schlechteste
dass da unten ihr habt euch wahrscheinlich meine mana anzeige wenn
die leer ist kann ich immer kassen deswegen höre ich jetzt auch mal auf und
holen hau mir den drank rein und setzt mich meine die ich setze mich mal in die
ramme die ramme ist voll dann mache ich einfach gar nix
bleibe ich einfach hier stehen guck dem zu wie ein paar mobs pullt warum auch
immer und rennen bisschen im kreis und gucken ob irgendwelche feinde kommen man
sieht hier wieder speed warp beste muss ohne speed warps geht nix
so ich muss mal gucken warum warum sind meine quick bindings warum funktionieren
die eigentlich nicht ich habe doch hier gesagt
windows tastet die linke windows tasten remapped auf sechs warum remapped das
nicht remapper key links continue das funktioniert nicht ich kann meine
kies nicht remappen warum denn warum denn das nicht das habe ich auf meinem
anderen account ganz genauso da funktioniert ich möchte nämlich quick
cast auf windows hast du haben das steht und ja das ist normal das ist normal
dass da unten steht das ist noch aber und mal vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht
muss ich tatsächlich
wo ist denn 6 f1 f6 wo ist sechs gibt es hier gar nicht keine ahnung
muss mal kurz dran bleiben
da ist unser nachschub ist da
ok dann mep ich jetzt dann dann mep ich jetzt mal schiff hier drauf ich überlege
gerade worauf habe ich das denn q binded hier drauf fack ich weiß meine
q bindings nicht mehr nee ok ich glaube ich hatte q bindings ich hatte caps lock
hatte ich glaube auf nein auf dem hier continue das remappen funktioniert nicht
leute habt ihr eine ahnung warum power toys irgendwie kaputt ist leute achtung
ink ink ink gegner bashen erst mal schön gestunt tengler tengler muss weg ich
hasse pilze gibt nix schlimmeres in dem game muss weg ich habe sie mitbekommen ich
habe sie mitbekommen dass wir abziehen monka es deswegen bin ich normalerweise
immer im discord damit ich das mitkriege stop chasing peanuts jawoll sind ganz
schön viele feinde da drüben
die trauen sich nicht kommen die trauen sich nicht rüber das würde ich an denen
ihrer stelle auch nicht machen übers übers wasser hier drüber schwimmen
ok die hängt die der steht der kriegt damage jawoll da unten ist er als gg
oh wir machen wir machen den massive wir machen den big brain flank leute big
brain flank torpedo nein machen wir nicht die haben es
gecheckt wir haben es gesehen
tengler ne kein tengler also das ist nicht die ganze hippie geht die sind
definitiv zu organisiert dafür komplett wegzugehen
immer schön an den speed warst speed warst vorbei da sind sie alter jetzt aber
da sind sie da sind sie schön von der seite rein schön von der seite rein
gatschi bass wie sie abhauen wie sie rennen back speed warst alter wie sie
rennen wie sie wegrennen
guck mal das sind 100 gegner die rennen einfach weg wahnsinn ich meine die
hätten sie ja mal open field open fight mal probieren können
hat noch ausgewischen dem speed war
wie viel haben wir dann eigentlich 21 uhr eine stunde mache ich noch heute aber wir
haben trotzdem ganz gut rps gemacht da sind sie da sind sie gib ihm gib ihm
gatschi bass drauf drauf speed warp stellen ich was ist nicht die rennen
immer noch jetzt seid ihr gefickt jetzt seid ihr richtig gefickt leute
guck mal der da der da ist besonders gefickt jetzt
daunisser next da sollte man übrigens nicht rein rennen in diese kreise da
kriegt man damage und wird geslot
hängler nein nein oh mann ich bin jetzt gut hängler so erst mal gepercht ich
war gerade für eine minute gerutet durch diesen kack pilz ich hasse diese pilze
es gibt nichts schlimmeres als tengler leute
mehr range mehr damage es ist krass wie die vor uns abhauen
guckt euch das an die rennen einfach weg vor uns das war eine kurze minute ja
weil ich meine sieben minuten sieben minuten cool down fähigkeit eingesetzt
hat der dass ich mich einmal daraus befreien kann die rennen mit 100 leuten
einfach vor uns weg und und und ein drittel der bg lassen sie hinterlassen
sie stehen und die snacken wir easy weg
leute vielleicht habt ihr ein bisschen ein bisschen eindruck davon bekommen
warum es best pvp game ever ist
so das beste was uns jetzt passieren kann ist dass noch ein paar mit dazu
kommen sieben minuten für nur für mich
hört schatz sieben minuten cool down sieben minuten 30 das heißt ich kann die
nächsten sieben minuten mich nicht mehr aus in einem cc befreien da bin ich auf
die anderen leute meiner gruppe angewiesen das zu machen als leute
irgendwie von euch angefangen haben oder anfangen wollen und irgendwelche
fragen haben sagen wir zu klassen was sie spielen sollen oder vielleicht zu
equipment könnt ihr ruhig alles reinhauen
ich spiele in kram seit 2001 also nicht dass ich der ober checker bin aber ich
denke das meiste kriege ich zusammen in dem spiel
wieder kiept aber da ist die halbe bg drin da können wir doch gar nicht
feiten richtig dagegen hier aus in mitz da sobald ihr diese komischen
hämmer seht wisst ihr mit sind am start die haben eine klasse also wie gesagt ich
zeige noch mal die drei reiche wie gesagt wir spielen albion wir sind in
hibernia aber es gibt drei reiche und es gibt eine klasse in mitgard die nennt
sich auf deutsch donner krieger und dreimal dürft ihr machen dreimal dürft
ihr raten was sie machen können es sind so komische so komische
hämmer und diese hämmer ist die dümmste fähigkeit im gesamten spiel die machen
kein damage und jegliches cc wird gebrochen es ist es ist einfach es ist
also ganz ehrlich die meisten spiel das einfach nur maximal hängen geblieben
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt wie man auf die auf die wende kommt auf die wende
kommt man nur als der so oder als oft hängt
donner krieger ist eine perfekte solo klar die ist solo tatsächlich gut ja und
mehr sollte ich auch hauptsächlich solo spielen man sollte nicht hämmer
reinhauen in gegner guckt euch an die brechen jegliches cc und ich klick die
gegner ich klick mal die leute an die die nehmen keinen damage also diese
hämmer machen minimal damage und brechen jegliches cc ich freue mich jedes mal
wenn ich hämmer sehe bin ich happy sobald ich hämmer sehe weiß ich ich kann
ohne probleme die nächsten fünf minuten laufen ohne dass was passiert
bei zauberin ist gerade starb kaputt gegangen weil ihr dürft nicht wissen die
items in diesem spiel am haltbarkeit wenn die unter 90 prozent haltbarkeit
trotten dann verlieren sie alle alle sachen die drauf sind was ziemlich
pepega ist und ihr sein stap ist gerade kaputt gegangen das heißt sprich als
keine fähigkeit und keine stats mehr auf sein stappen
machen wir denn hier eigentlich gerade
problemo loop
so gleich wird es wieder hell wird auch mal zeit ich hasse nacht in daug
da gegners attacke torpedo nein nein nein nicht in den nicht in den
turm rein wieder die da torpedo die sind zu schnell noch mehr
da ist einer du bleibstehen du bleibstehen jawoll da steht er
hätte nicht stehen bleiben sollen und speed warp setzen jetzt ist er tot
ich meine dir bleibt nichts anderes übrig wenn du die habt ja gesehen das
waren acht gegner wenn wenn 150 alps auf dich zu rennen bleibt dir nichts anderes
übrig wie speed wie speed warp stellen und abhauen was willst du machen also
du kannst eigentlich normalerweise nicht frontal acht versus 150 das geht nicht
da bist du dauernd das einzige was du machen kannst ist diese bomben action die
vorhin die die mit mitgruppe mit uns gemacht hat wenn sie uns blöd erwischt
aber das passiert auch nur wenn die alps alle so laufen wie man das hier sieht
alle im stick alle auf einem klumpen deswegen sollte man das auch nicht machen
guck mal da was ist denn da hips hips hip ich die raus
keine chance man muss aufpassen also polimo nimmt da keine rücksicht drauf
wenn du jetzt hier geslaut wirst der rennt einfach weiter mit seinem zerk
keine chance also wusste echt auf zack sein kann es hier nicht kann es hier
nicht einfach brain afk rumzergen und alles hitten da bist du tot würde gern
mal so würde gern mal so einen vibe sehen der chat würde brennen hier was
für einen vibe meinst du wir sind doch vorhin gewalbt am an ali man hat nicht
viel gesehen weil ich dumm gelegen habe
leute ich hoffe ihr habt spaß am stream es ist einfach mal was anderes als
sonst normalerweise mache ich ja was ganz anderes aber ich habe so oft
erzählt ich spiele daug und ich habe dauerklänge gespielt und ich spiele
gerade wieder auf dem freestand und alle immer gefällt max was ist für ein game
jetzt streben wir mal eine runde du raffst zwar nichts ja es ist auch
schwierig es ist schwierig also ehrlich gesagt wenn man das spiel nie gespielt
hat und das jetzt zum ersten mal gerade hier diese wie soll man sagen ja groß auf
großer skala hier pvp kämpfe sieht du verstehst auch nichts du verstehst
auch nichts gut zum einschlafen ist nice andere gucken da erst mal streams für
das problem ist nur ich habe heute morgen stream gemacht
und danach habe ich gespielt mit den jungs hier mit den jungs und medels hier
und jetzt bin ich schon wieder drei stunden und ich habe heute eindeutig
wieder zu viel kreise klein gemacht bin ich ganz sicher wo wir hin wollen
ehrlich gesagt aber ich werde auch nichts vorlesen was im chat steht
mu fa sa ist da übrigens übelst übelst lustiger name wie ich finde er ist eine kuh und heißt
mu fa sa ich weiß null weh haha cringe ich finde es eine gute sache alter was ja wie
was was was genau machen wir hier
chat in game chat weit mich mal bitte ein was machen wir hier jetzt gerade außer außer
am turm stehen was ist der plan
wir reparieren den turm wir haben den turm repariert ja das ist auch was man kann türme
und türen reparieren wenn die kaputt sind habe ich noch nie gemacht ich habe ich spiele
das spiel legit 20 jahre immer mal on off aber ich habe noch nie einen turm beziehungsweise
eine tür repariert in diesem spiel ich habe auch noch nie den crafter gelevelt ich bin
einfach niemand der craftet in mmos dabei hat da auch ein richtig gutes crafting system
wenn man live spielt auf selestius nicht wenn man live spieler da auch finde ich eines der
besten crafting systeme weil in da hat halt spieler hergestelltes equipment noch wirklich
seinen sinn auf selestius nicht auf selestius gibt es kein craft das crafting system an
sich ist vielleicht nicht geil aber dass spieler also dass spieler hergestelltes equipment
eben gebraucht wird finde ich gut mein gelden chat ist da mein crafting system ist nicht
so geil die lay viel zu klein warum du kannst es nicht streamen mit mit delay kannst nicht
mit dem chat reden es gibt nur zwei varianten mit delay stream bedeutet gar nicht stream
oder ohne delay stream ich kann ich mit die leistung ist kacke wenn irgendjemand was fragt
oder wenn du irgendwas zu dem spiel erzählen willst was im chat ist du kannst nicht darauf
reagieren wenn du mit delay streams hab den chat zensiert ich hab den discord aus so dass
ihr nicht hört mehr mehr kann ich nicht machen
ich soll die lay stream ok jo dann mach ich dann muss ich den stream ausmachen soll ich
kann ich mit die lay stream funktioniert nicht also leute wir sehen uns bis denn macht's
gut see you